we've got some new tour dates to
announce
we've added a show in wichita
october 11th
the october 12th show is sold out we
will now be there tuesday night october
11th wichita kansas at the orpheum
theater october 13th in omaha nebraska
at the holland performing arts center in
october 14th denver colorado paramount
theater we have two shows that night
we've added a late show
get your tickets at theovonne.com
t-o-u-r
we want you to go through that link that
way you're getting um
accurately priced
because you go through uh side links and
stuff you'll get priced out
so uh we look forward to seeing you at
the return of the rat tour i'll be there
baby gang i want to let you know that we
have new gang gang merch
it's out there baby get those hitters
we got a couple different colorways my
mom likes them
she wears them when she's out on her
route
so i hope you check them out they've got
white
and they got pink and they got baby blue
if you're feeling like a baby or if you
got the blues or if you don't and you
just damn well like that color check
those out and more at theovonstore.com
today's guest is a man of science
he has a doctorate in philosophy from
ucla
and he's most known for his work in
cryonics
and if you're wondering what cryonics is
well it's basically that he freezes your
body when you die
in hopes that they will be able to bring
you back to life in the future
it's a fascinating world to learn about
i think you're going to love it i did
we had a great conversation about life
and death
and the afterlife
today's guest is dr max
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr max moore do i call you doctor is
that oh i insist no no no
okay okay um
so yeah you were saying you didn't sleep
that good last night
yeah i don't know what happened it was
uh i get i get problems with congestion
and and um i've got psychic nerve damage
so sometimes my foot is numb and i had
both of those last night and uh i took a
sleepy pill which shouldn't last more
than four hours and that didn't work
after an hour and a half i took another
one and that was probably a mistake
oh yeah that's always when you get that
double up yeah but it shouldn't
shouldn't have kept me asleep at that
time so i was going to get up at 7 30
get some work done and then i get the
call it's 10 o'clock and i go oh my god
so i wish i could have around about uh
15 minutes or so 20 minutes well we're
glad you made it in man it's interesting
that you didn't get much sleep but that
you're kind of like the eternal sleep
guy you know
like um
i just want to preface for our audience
so
people always like talk you always hear
about like living forever people are
always like i'm gonna live you know i'd
love to how do we you know and people
are always like well you can get frozen
you know you know you can get frozen
like um you know they always say
different people that are frozen and
like kirby puck it's frozen or
um you know walt disney's fro you know
there's that company
right you can hear you can always hear
that right people always hear that just
like in like uh
just human interaction societal chatter
but that's actually what you do
that's your world that's what i do i
will have to come back to a couple of
things you mentioned by walt disney
about freezing okay uh some of those
stuff but yeah that's what we do
cryonics right bionics not to be
confused with cryogenics okay so let's
start there let's start there so what is
cryonics so we can get it cryonics is
essentially the preservation of people
at the point of legal death not the same
as biological death uh and to very
simplify the process that we can go into
it's the preservation of people at the
point of legal death at extremely cold
temperatures minus 320 fahrenheit uh in
the
hopes that in the future and we're
talking about decades to a century or so
in the future we may have the technology
to fix whatever killed you in today's
sense uh revive you and bring you back
so you can carry on living at the most
simple wow
wow
bo so yeah you're the guy that like yeah
i want to have an iou from i feel like
you know um and so what is cryogenics
then what's the other side of that and
there's some water too yeah there's a
bunch of cryo terms so cryogenics is
simply the engineering of low
temperatures okay so lots of people use
cryogenics you know chip companies use
liquid nitrogen to cool at their labs
that's cryogenics uh you know freezes
that go below pretty cold temperatures
colder than once we have at home that's
cryogenics uh the editor of the
cryogenics magazine wrote an editorial a
couple of years ago complaining that
people keep calling cryonics cryogenics
because they're different things ah so
this is a cryobiology which is simply
the study of the effects of very low
temperatures on living things uh and
then this is crowd preservation so
there's a lot of these crayons okay a
lot of cry yeah so cryo preservation
though this is an important one cryo
preservation is the application of very
cold temperatures to living things now
this is important because if you think
about it there are millions of people
walking around today who are
cryopreserved they were just embryos at
the time in vitro fertilization you take
an embryo you cryopreserve it you keep
it at liquid notion temperature wow
so there's a lot of those freezer burn
babies just running around on the planet
there's a lot of there's no freezer burn
but yeah they were cryopreserved uh some
people have corneas or heart valves or
skin that was cryopreserved so that's
something we can cry preserve and we can
bring that back today unlike human
beings as a whole which is a more
complicated issue
wow so so but the world that you
facilitate basically or have facilitated
is in cryonics right
and you guys are the company
that
when someone i guess registers with your
company they want to be they want to
take that long shot they're playing the
long game they want to be frozen yeah
the basic idea is that someone uh in
almost all cases someone makes these
arrangements way in advance years or
decades in advance we very rarely take
people who call us up at the last minute
because we don't be seen as taking
advantage of people for one thing when
you're not thinking straight at the end
of your life
plus it's actually legally risky because
maybe the relatives are against the idea
so people generally sign up well in
advance and fill out all the contracts
and make sure we understand what they're
doing they have to make the right
financial arrangements because obviously
this is something that costs money and
if we go through this whole thing and
don't get paid it's going to threaten
the organization right so all that has
been put in place and then at the point
when your body gives out i don't want to
call die because that's not not really
what's happening we'll get into that
it's the are you actually dead or not
because i don't think you are but your
body gives out your heart fails whatever
something critical goes uh in an ideal
situation we're right there at the
bedside and we can begin within seconds
of legal death being pronounced and do
you have to wait for someone to be there
like does a coroner have to show up or
like at least you know kind of smart
policeman or something to say hey yeah
you guys are good to get in there
they're dead generally no um
we hate those cases when you have
coroners or or medical examiners
in most cases you just wait for a doctor
to declare legal death uh i think in
some cases it can be a special kind of
nurse but legal death has to be declared
and it's very important to understand
how that's different from other things
now but you know coroners or medical
examiners that's a disaster when they
get involved because you have to wait
for them to arrive which could be an
hour or more and they're slow so i mean
they're dawdling they take their time
yeah and they have like gods they have
complete power it doesn't matter if you
have a religious objection they can do
it anyway and they often will and that
can be a disaster that can be as bad as
taking the brain out of your head
slicing into pieces uh and then shoving
it back into your stomach which is as
nasty as it sounds
it doesn't have to be that bad uh we've
had a lot of success in i mean they will
autopsy if you're driving a car you have
an accident they're going to autopsy you
okay slow it down a little bit for me so
i can pay yeah i am yeah i'm i'm so
you're okay so you have
so the corners and those kind of guys
can be a hindrance it can be a hold up
so you want to be already involved with
the presumed patient that you're going
to freeze you want to be already
involved with them and hopefully there's
like a medical per there you know at the
end of their life with a doctor or
they're in hospice
or hospice someone can
someone can pronounce pronounce them
legally dead and then you guys can be
there right and right then you guys
start
what do you do like write like
do you give them a couple minutes to
kind of like be like with the lord or
whatever do you just get right in there
we get right in there
ideally i mean we're not always able to
get there before needle death is
pronounced we want to get there as quick
as we can it's not essential but it's
certainly better so ideally we're at the
bedside the doctor says i declare you
legally dead okay and let's just go into
that for a second before we go on to the
procedure because it's really important
when they say i i declare you legally
there what does that mean exactly does
it mean your whole body's dead all your
cells are dead no
it can't mean that because people donate
their organs all the time right so all
these things are still alive just
something critical has failed and in
fact many times when you're declared
legally dead they could actually
resuscitate you that's why people have
dnr do not resuscitate orders because
they're saying please don't resuscitate
me because i'm just gonna be miserable
and horrible for a couple of hours and
then fail again right wow so it's very
important that legal death is not the
same as everything suddenly dying that
doesn't happen i see so it just has to
be legally dead and then there's still a
lot of life going on inside people yeah
so that's when you guys get in that's
when we get in there and what we do uh
try and keep it relatively simple
because it's a complex procedure
basically we'll take the patient move
them from the hospital bed or the
hospice bed into an ice bath we'll cover
them with ice add some water we have a
device that circulates that icy slurry
around them to accelerate the cooling
process and what temperature is that you
put them in well it's just yeah it's
just ice water so okay we don't want to
go below freezing at this point because
that would damage the cells we haven't
protected them yet so um we're going to
put icy water this starts circulating
we'll put on a mechanical cpr device to
start pumping on their chest and a
respirator to take over breathing so
we're actually restarting circulation
and respiration you might say why are
you doing that this person's dead well
as you said they're not really dead in
any interesting sense and we have to
preserve the viability of the tissues
just like someone donating an organ or a
kidney we want to keep it viable there
you have to keep it viable for several
hours while you send it across country
yeah when i was young my sister got a
liver transplant when i was younger when
we were kids
and she um
yeah i guess they had to move the organ
pretty quick and then get it in there
yeah they don't last that long anyway
yeah sorry i don't know why i went on
that tangent but um okay so you have the
body now
when you're when you're well just
there's a bit more to go but when you
apply that process do they ever come
back to life in that moment no and
that's what the next thing next thing
i'm going to get right so sorry
don't don't dumb the gun yeah no no
that's a very important point though
because that could happen you're quite
right to think about it that is possible
theoretically again because just because
they call you legally dead doesn't mean
everything is stopped right so uh once
we do this once we do the cooling we're
also applying various medications we
have a series of 10 or 12 medications
the first of which is propofol now i
used to have to explain what propofol is
but since michael jackson most people
have heard yeah yeah that's that party
yeah he did a little too much of it yeah
he did a lot i guess uh there's two
reasons for that first of all let's move
this mic over a little bit on you sorry
how's that just this way a little yeah
there you go okay okay um there's two
reasons yeah michael jackson did it he
uh he definitely
yeah if he was still alive he would be
selling the drug
that's right now
the reason for the propofol is twofold
first of all it slows down brain
metabolism and that's very important
because the first your metabolism is
running the first of things are going to
fall apart so we want to slow that down
the other thing is it will prevent any
return to consciousness
which is possible as we've said it's
unlikely but it wouldn't necessarily be
a full return to consciousness like hey
what's going on guys it could just be
some kind of sense of oh i feel really
cold and unpleasant so we want to
prevent that completely so that's why we
give that as the first medication
wow so that's the one that's going to
cut off any chance of a real somebody
popping back to life
but at that point they've been declared
legally dead so they're so societally
you're cleared and then they've already
chosen that they want to be frozen so
they've dialed in
so then at that point once you get the
propofol and it slows the brain
metabolism yeah is that the same as like
a metabolism you have in your stomach
and stuff yeah it's just it's just
biological metabolism in the brain so
we're actually slowing everything down
but the important part for us is the
brain because that's the most important
thing and we should talk more about that
because some people just want to
preserve the brains and we can
understand that yeah yeah i've heard
that man look these are the rumors these
are the things people are saying that's
why i'm glad i'm sitting here um with
the savant of afterlife man um okay cool
so we got the body you got the propofol
in there so we've got a bunch more
things to put in there we're going to
put in again i won't go into all the
details of it but various other drugs to
uh stop the blood from clotting for
instance to maintain blood pressure like
an antifreeze or something not yet okay
that's antifreeze right so anticoagulant
okay exactly yeah the anti-freeze stuff
will come later oh damn so there's a
bunch of things we put in based on the
research we do to again at this stage
people in the hospital go oh and i i get
what you're doing this looks very much
like donating organs you're trying to
keep them as alive as possible while you
transport them somewhere else so this
problem makes perfect sense to people in
hospitals okay and at this point are you
and i you had a video you pulled up zach
is that
yeah we actually uh we found a video on
the alcor website kind of talking you
know going through this process if you
does this help us at all max
yeah it's probably one of my max if you
want to maybe walk us through this sure
i think it's one of the videos i did
about 10 years or so ago
this is some generic pictures of people
in hospitals
so yeah that's the railway there you can
see you know you've got a respirator you
get artificial oh okay i'm moving the
patient into a nice birth here okay this
is what you just told us about yeah okay
so that they added the bed into the ice
bath it's a little different than what
we do now but it's basically the process
gonna cover the patient to nice
in the ice path we use today we actually
circulate the icy water which is more
efficient than just packing the patient
in ice like that
yeah got it yeah but there it is you
know we really want to start the cooling
because
there's actually an equation that tells
you that if you drop 10 degrees c in
temperature your metabolism will slow
down by 50 so if you can get down
three lots of 10 degrees so you've
slowed down to a half a quarter an
eighth of the speed which means you've
got eight times as much time to
transport the patients wow so they said
that's why they call organs when they're
transporting them too so you want to get
them cold quick yeah so here they've
arrived at the alcohol facility the
surgeon has been called in and um i'm
assuming there's a whole body patient
they're going to open up the chest and
what's called a median stenotomy
basically just cut open the chest okay
uh they're going to access the major
blood vessels of the heart
this is still working on the surgery
part
so this is all taking place above
freezing it's important to understand we
haven't gone below freezing at this
point so here they're connecting up
these tubes are basically connecting up
the patient's vascular system their
blood vessels to our pump and chiller
system
and what we're going to do over the next
several hours under computer control is
to pump out as much of the blood and
intracellular fluid as we can and then
you can see basically the perfusion
machine that's doing the pumping it's
going to take as much blood and other
fluids as possible and replace it with a
kind of a medical grade antifreeze okay
and do you save the blood and stuff that
you pull out no we don't need to say
that like that's something that's easily
replaceable we do that all the time even
today
um so we're replacing with that well the
medical that's me talking about it okay
so the medical grade antifreeze or
cryoprotectant as we call it
um we actually use the same
cryoprotectant that's being used in
research right now for human organ
cryopreservation now we talked about how
people try to donate the organs and yeah
you have to get them from here to to
whatever state the person's in hopefully
in time and it's a lot of them don't
make it in time and so we lose tens of
thousands of people every year because
they can't get the organs in time so the
goal is and this is very relevant to
what we're doing and there's a lab right
here actually in california that does
this uh not too far away
the goal is to take organs and crowd
preserved them
just like we do hold them down at
extremely cold temperatures you can keep
them for you know for months or years if
necessary keep them in a hospital bank
and then
rewarm them and then as the patient
needs them they're right there you don't
have to worry about transporting them
you could save many tens of thousands of
lives a year and we're on the cusp of
doing that right now the company's
actually achieved successful
freezing or actually not freezing we'll
get into that basically freezing of
rabbit kidneys re-implanting them and
having them function well and
re-implanting in the same rabbit are
different right the same one okay yeah
but do they have the can you go to a
different body yet like with that with
that sort of thing because what i'm
hearing you say is that at hospitals
well it can go into different you could
go on a different one yeah but then
you've got issues of yeah possible
rejection the more different the
creature is although that's something i
think we'll we'll figure out pretty soon
we're getting some good progress there
but what you're saying or what i'm
hearing is that
you can take the organs out of someone
or some someone
and save them preserve them right at a
hospital yep hypothetically this is what
we're getting close to
and then if someone was in the hospital
and needed an organ they would be able
to take one and put it in them exactly
right and so just to emphasize we
already do this not with organs because
organs are more complex we already do
this with things like corneas heart
valves skin
um obviously eggs sperm embryos so
people say oh you this chronic is crazy
because you can't unfreeze something
well you don't know what the hell are
you talking about of course just think
about it for a minute of course we do we
do this all the time it's just the
difficult part is actually the rewarming
and the more complex the tissue we're
talking about once we go from a tissue
to an organ it gets difficult that's why
it's the cutting edge today and going
from an organ to a whole body that's
something we can't do today
right but are you really gonna say if we
can't do it today it's impossible
yeah we went from cigarettes to vaping
we went from biplanes to landing on the
moon yeah we went from the unicycle to
uh
i don't know what nothing i mean
unicycle was kind of a piece of [ __ ] but
um i mean we've done so yeah we continue
to do some amazing things you know so i
agree
so
sorry i have so many ways to go in here
um should we finish kind of going
through the process because we're
getting yeah this is better the less i
talk the better
i'm serious no so i mean yeah it's
something you have to kind of really
know the details of so at that point uh
after several hours of replacing the
blood uh we finished what's called
perfusing the body we replaced the blood
with these fluids oh wait i didn't have
one question yeah sorry so the organs
you took them out of that no no you
didn't the organs are still in we don't
need to do that no no okay not for what
we do okay that's the other kind of
research but okay you've just gone into
the
into the main arteries and stuff and
started to take the blood out and put in
the antifreeze exactly okay that takes a
few hours because if you just throw it
in there at high concentration when the
patient's still relatively warm it's
pretty toxic to the cells so we have to
start off with a low concentration and
gradually wrap that up over time over a
few hours so it's all very well
researched to optimize this at the end
of that process we can then drop from
just above freezing it's about plus
three degrees c down to about minus
three and then we uh we put this kind of
wrap across the patient start pumping in
liquid nitrogen vapor
that starts the raspberry cooling and
then we're going to move them eventually
to another room where we'll
put them another container and then
plunge the temperature very rapidly to
about minus 90 degrees c
but you know your freezer box holds at
minus 20 so it's minus 90 that's just to
start with and then we slow down a bit
to let the temperature kind of equal out
throughout the body and eventually we're
going to go down a little more slowly
all the way down to uh minus 196 celsius
or minus 320 minus 320 fahrenheit that's
the that's the devil's produce
at that point man you're really
dude you're deep then you're very deep
you're so cold that basically you could
wait for a thousand years and you'd be
just as fresh as when you started once
you go below a certain temperature
basically nothing is happening there's
no metabolism whatsoever really so at
that point you're not going to no so at
that point you're not going to decay at
all not at all at all no wow not in the
least
so you are really stuck i mean you are
you're
is is any part of you still living at
that point no you're not living but this
is actually a really important
discussion we get really philosophical
about this um you're not living because
life implies metabolism and activity and
obviously we've stopped all of that
happening but you're not dead either
because dead implies that you've gone
beyond repair right you've gone forever
and that's that's not the case either
just as we've seen with the case with
skin cells and corneas and other things
that we can
they're not alive because they're not
functioning but we can bring them back
yeah just like like tom brady
you know so yeah so death is not a clear
concept actually um at least most people
don't have a clear idea of what death
really is so we talked about clinical
death that's just when a doctor says i
declare you well sorry not that's a
legal death legal that is where a doctor
says i'm going to call you dead maybe i
can bring you back you know but i'm
going to call you dead i'm giving up at
this point because there's nothing more
i can do clinical death is different
right clinical death is just when you
stop breathing and your heart stops
beating that's it those are the two
requirements yeah but in the old days
that was death to people like before
about 1960 you know if we were talking
and you were so excited about what i was
saying that you just went oh oh oh and
you had a heart attack and you stopped
reading we check your polls so just like
in the old celtics he's dead jim that
was it we gave up yeah we don't do that
today someone would jump on you to start
doing cpr and defibrillation we'd be
shocking you and probably bring you back
so what we said was dead before about
1960 we don't consider dead today we
consider in need of help so be so dead
keeps evolving yeah the difference what
we call that what we call dead keeps
evolving and keeps changing yeah wow
that's interesting and today sometimes
you know we had the idea of brain death
to take it further so in our view when
someone declares you legally dead
um you're also clinically dead at that
point you're not really dead in some fun
if we if by death we mean irreversible
you're gone forever you're not dead
because almost everything in your body
is still alive now you will be dead if
we don't intervene and stop things
decaying you know if you do what most
people do which to me is completely
crazy throw you in the ground to beat my
worms and bacteria or shove you into a
gigantic oven to be incinerated which is
just crazy stuff to me yeah at that
point yeah you can't really do that you
can't be reheated that's right now what
about this so
with clinical death and legal death is
that where they're then able to take
organs and donate them yes
so so that's interesting so after
clinical and legal death
you still have organs that go and can
live in someone else exactly
man that's a pretty good insight of what
could be possible one day and that's an
interesting point about that there's
also something called uh donation after
cardiac death which means that actually
your brain in principle your brain could
still be functional when they take your
organs out wow you got to be really
really generous to do that
that's something they could in principle
do so this idea of dead is actually a
lot more complex than people will
realize they often talk about crying and
say well look dead is dead so it's
impossible well what kind of death are
we talking about here this yeah there's
different kinds it'd be crazy if you're
like at us you're you're like at a
street corner some guy gets hit by a bus
and people are like he's dead and you're
like is he no you better that's why we
call the emergency medical services
because you know just because they're
not breathing doesn't mean that they're
dead yet wow man if you hate your phone
bill
if you look at that thing and say dang i
hate you
then that's probably because you're
getting ripped off
by fine print contracts from big
wireless providers
so i want to tell you about mint mobile
they offer premium wireless starting at
just 15 bucks a month
you might be wondering what's the catch
buddy
well there isn't one mint mobile's
secret sauce is that they're the first
company to sell wireless service online
only
they cut out the cost of retail stores
and pass those sweet savings directly to
you
that's right all plans come with
unlimited talk and text unlimited and
high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network
you can use your own phone with mint
mobile as well
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free
go to mintmobile.com
theo that's m i n t m o b i l e dot com
slash t t-a-g-o
cut your wireless bill of 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com
theo and now a word from our sponsor
betterhelp
how well do you take care of your car
maybe you got that dodge neon
like mom used to have or maybe you got
that ford taurus
and you're out there you're polishing
and waxing and washing it
sometimes you might even wash it at
night because you're lonely
well
your brain is no different it needs to
be taken care of
it needs to be waxed and washed and
examined to make sure that it's running
smooth
that's where better help online therapy
can be supportive
better help
it's online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat therapy
sessions
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera even
if you're embarrassed of something or
you don't feel like you can yet
better help
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours i've used it
and it works
our listeners get percent off their
first month at betterhelp.com
theo that's betterhelp.com
theo
yeah it's interesting to to start to
think about yeah what is the idea of
death and when is it but we already have
three
two we have legal death clinical death
and then we have the point where you've
incinerated or gotten you know damaged
the whatever's left so badly that's
really
irreversible and to you that's real yeah
and we have a special term for that
which will sound very very highfalutin
probably because it's
some of us are philosophers like myself
so we call this information theoretic
death now it's not as complicated it
sounds basically the idea is well
obviously let's say you're in a plane
crash and you were totally incinerated
on the crash are you dead well yes
you're dead because there's no
conceivable technology that could ever
fix you so either if you gathered your
ashes and frozen nobody could ever fix
that yeah um but if uh
to take an example let's say that um
let's say theo that you're doing some
kind of nefarious thing you're thinking
about robbing a bank or doing something
like that and you you're kind of sitting
in your chair here kind of writing it
down on a piece of paper okay first of
all i'm gonna i've got to buy the guns
here and then i've got to find out how
to get through the locks and then i
gotta yeah all your plans detail them
[Laughter]
yeah exactly so you've got your plan on
this piece of paper and you think oh god
that was so stupid why did i write that
down someone's going to find this you
know the fbi has been maybe sniffing
around and so you take the paper you
shred it in one direction you shred it
and the other you throw it in the trash
you think
okay i'm safe now no you're not because
if the nsa has been watching you because
they know what kind of guy you are come
on they probably are oh yeah they
definitely i've gotten a couple of no i
haven't got an actual mail but i've
gotten emails that say i got to tone it
down so they got their eye on you so
they're going to go into your trash
they're going to fish that out they're
going to lay it out they're going to
scan it run it through a very computer
very clever computer algorithm and
they're going to reconstruct what you
thought you'd destroyed
and if you think about the brain it's
like a three-dimensional version of that
piece of paper you could do a lot of
damage actually to the brain you can
damage the cell membranes poke holes in
them uh change some of the chemistry it
doesn't mean that you could ever repair
it so long as there's enough information
left in the brain that some advanced
technology like an advanced molecular
nanotechnology maybe generate run by
artificial intelligence whatever if it
can put those pieces back where they
were
then you could actually bring back the
function of the human being so that's
why we call information theoretic death
if you've lost too much information
there's too much damage it's really
obliterated then you're dead but beyond
that point you're not because more
advanced technology could in principle
repair you now we don't know for sure
that's going to happen but it seems like
a pretty good bet we're going to get
better and better at repairing people
that's a pretty reasonable assumption i
think yeah i agree i mean well
technology just keeps advancing you know
even if you wanted it not to at this
point we could it
it's impossible to for us to even stop
there was an article the other there was
something the other day about some pigs
i saw
yeah on uh i think it was even on tmz
here it is right here dead pigs come
back to life
did you see this yeah yeah this is very
interesting research it was heartbeat
returns during experiment i'm just gonna
a group of pigs was pronounced dead for
hours as part of a study
um
and
and then incredibly
uh i can't go back
and then incredibly scientists got it
beating again um
staggering few researchers from yale
begin pumping synthetic fluids through
the bodies of dead pigs getting their
hearts to faintly beat
um so after about five hours of what
would be considered death normally so
was this like do you know this has been
going on for a long time or was this
news to you uh this was well this was
news in a sense but it wasn't a surprise
the same researchers actually did
something in 2019 that was fairly
similar they kind of extrapolated a
little bit further and back in the 80s
we don't do any animal research anymore
because it makes you a big target for
various people but back in the 80s we uh
or an associated lab did some work with
dogs where they would basically take out
all the blood from the dogs replace it
with a saline based solution
um and then chill them down to just that
four degrees c above freezing hold them
there for several hours like four four
hours replace the blood re-warm them and
they came back and they were perfectly
fine they were neurologically intact
they recognized people everything was
fine so it's kind of a little bit
similar to what they're doing with the
pigs so they took the blood out of the
dogs yeah put it back and replaced with
a saline solution for a few hours and
resupported the circulation you know
externally because the heart wasn't
beating on its own okay right so then
kept it alive yeah with uh machines
and then brought it back to life and so
the dog knew what was going on knew
where it turned out yeah so much like
they're doing with the pig so that's
actually very advanced research because
we had um there's a guy called dr peter
ree who actually used to be clinton's
personal physician and he's a real
expert in this area and he realized that
using low temperature surgery uh is
pretty good stuff because there are some
people you can't operate on like if you
have a gunshot wound you're going to
tend to bleed out really fast and trying
to get you to a hospital and operate on
you in time
usually hopeless so he thought well what
if we could cool people down a lot more
than we do today because we do sometimes
cool people for like brain surgery we'll
take them down a few degrees he said
what if we could take people down all
the way to 10 degrees c above freezing
which is pretty chilly
and the idea is that again as you drop
in temperature your metabolism slows
down and that would buy you about four
times as much time so if you had only 10
minutes to operate you've got 40 minutes
and so on
and oh i see so at a certain so the
the colder you have the more preserved
you are
yeah your body from metabolizing exactly
and slowing that then that equates to
multiplying the amount of time that you
have exactly uh to operate on the body
as it is
so now i don't know if he's actually
started the study yet it was supposed to
be in for pittsburgh maybe there's a lot
of gunshot wound victims there or
something but i think they've moved it i
don't know they've started doing it yet
but they've done it in animals and it
does work um and he actually came to
visit us in in arizona at alcor and he
said well what you're doing is more
radical what i'm doing but it's
basically the same principle and then
you know made sense and so so now you
guys have the body you have so that's
your clientele you freeze them down you
get the fluids into them do you keep the
organs in them i guess it depends on if
it's a full body
yeah well we know we keep everything in
there okay um but yeah there's a basic
choice about half our members choose to
preserve the entire body and the other
half including myself just preserved the
brain now as a practical matter we leave
the brain inside the skull because it's
actually kind of hard to remove it
without damaging it and it's just a
useful protective box anyway so no point
removing it but the thing you want is
the brain because everything else you
can have to regenerate and you might
think well why do you want to do that
it's not like futurama where you'll be
zipping around on a flying saucer to
keep your head going or something well
no the idea is that um given the kind of
technology we'll need to repair
you know
70 85 billion damaged neurons plus all
the trillions of blood cells in the body
that kind of technology should be able
to regenerate a body pretty easily um
that's actually relatively easy well i
say easy
it's a nearer term problem then be able
to repair a brain we can already start
to grow at least proto-organs in the lab
basic organs we can grow today out of
stomachs and the liver regrows the liver
grows part of itself right the liver is
the only thing that humans are really
bad at this we're just terrible compared
to animals you can chop their arms off
some of them and they regrow their arm
or worms grow half their bodies pass
themselves yeah just humans are lousy at
this when we're embryos we can actually
regenerate parts but basically we can
generate part of our liver unless we
drink too much maybe but we could do a
little bit of limit we can maybe get the
tip of our finger back and that's it
we're just terrible but that's because
we have the wrong genetic sequence right
we can get in there we can alter that we
should better program the body to regrow
parts and we're starting to grow things
in the lab today so to me regrowing a
body is actually going to be a lot
sooner than repairing a brain i think
we'll do that in the next you know 20
years or so whereas the brain's going to
take longer so my logic is why should i
take my whole body which hopefully if i
you know i won't die early it's going to
be a really lousy condition by the time
that happens uh it's just gonna be easy
to grow a new one probably right and
you'd want a new one too nobody's if
somebody look man if you bring me back
honestly dr max if you bring me back and
i'm in my same old body and i can't
you know go on dates or you know do
hoops or anything like that bro i'm not
going to want to be there exactly no
yeah the idea is and it's a good thing
you bring that up because it always kind
of amazes me that people think that's
what you do of course you're not going
to bring back someone as a 95 year old
what's the point the idea is you're
going to rejuvenate the body with that
kind of technology you're going to
rejuvenate the body reverse the aging
process and fix it so you don't age
further and yeah you'll be in your best
body that you ever had and
i would i would assume that there will
be options either before they bring you
back fully or right afterwards they're
going to say well okay we'll bring you
back in your best body you ever had but
shall we also fix your short-sightedness
do you want to fix that back problem
you've had for your yeah your entire
life or l5 s1 yeah yeah but do they um
but so but now does this
does the size of a brain grow over time
so could you
would you have to bring the body back
say say you okay so there's a lot of
ways to go there's a lot of ways to go
here so
okay so
first what are the options that you guys
offer for freezing just so i know for
the cryonics process at alcor that's
your company alcor and what what what
are the
the options like what's the packages
i should say by when you say a company
it's actually a non-profit organization
where a 501c texas a nonprofit
organization okay and that's important
to us because as a profit-making company
i've got nothing against that but it
tends to not survive very long if you
look at them historically whereas
non-profits educational organizations
religious organizations they can survive
for centuries that's why we're set up
that way so we nobody actually makes
profits from this we you know we have
salary stuff of course nobody makes
profits it's fact well it i love that
man it's fascinating because yeah i mean
you guys are basically like um
like death like magellan's i mean you
guys are out there just like you know
that's that's a good analogy i think
that's a good analogy because when
people say well what kind of people do
this
um well there are a number of factors
but one of them that's really critical
is you have to be an explorer i mean if
you think about i've talked to so many
people about this and
those who say well yeah i can i can see
how this could work this is not
implausible and then they go but oh my
god this might work that's that's scary
because they think about coming back
into a future maybe 100 years from now
everything's radically different their
skills are outdated they don't know
anybody and it horrifies them yeah which
i think is one big reason why there
aren't more people doing this uh it
tends to appeal to people who have you
know a magellan type personality and
explore a personality who look on that
and say well yeah it's gonna take some
getting used to although the
organization part of its mission is to
help you get you know rehabilitated yeah
you got to be brave because you're going
to go see your buddy and he's going to
be like 70 years older
or you're going to go or he's going to
be gone all your like a lot of your
friends might be gone or say if you died
at like 21 and you got froze and you
come back 40 years later you're going to
go over to your friend's house he's
going to be 60 you know it's like
everything's going to be
actually probably not that because
again the technology we're talking about
to reverse all the damage that's been
done by that point that you've legally
died plus the extra damage done in the
process we will fix the aging problem
before we bring people back so at least
your friend yeah they may be 80 years
older but they won't look 80 years older
but yeah they'll still be that huge gap
in experience obviously
now it's better if you can persuade your
friends and family to come with you yeah
yeah i know quite a few people i know a
number of people already cry preserved
and i have my wife has signed up for
this and a lot of my friends are so i
don't have that problem so much i know
some people but not everybody will but
you know i'd still rather come back not
knowing anybody i mean i came from i
came from england to los angeles back in
the 80s and i didn't really know anybody
and and it was a weird place here you
had this kind of bright object shining
from the sky instead of water falling on
me which is what what's up with that
people driving on the road yeah people
driving on the wrong side of the road
and stuff but we came over here yeah in
the 1700s and we didn't know anybody
yeah you know
um exactly it's like a journey through
time instead of a journey through space
dude that's so there's so many things
going on here man so
but also you're going to bring your wife
bro that's a risky move huh
why is that risky i mean i think it's
great i think it's very honorable and
it's very it's it's very sweet and kind
but what if like dude you know
it just see you gotta really be dialed
in for like you know because you only
said what for like what is the vow it's
like oh we didn't do that one though oh
it's still death to us part you should
have said till legal death do us part
yeah we didn't do that one because we
have a problem with the idea of death so
no it does bring out some interesting
questions because yeah i mean okay
you've got 50 years together 70 years
ago okay but what about a thousand years
together
so but you know we'll worry about that
warning yes
yeah that's a good call
so yeah you have to think of these
people yeah because you
i think in the simplistic mind
which i happen to possess thankfully for
the both of us um it's you just think
like the the the and the animal the the
the neanderthal thoughts are like i'm
gonna live forever
uh i'm gonna come back but you don't
think about after that like do you
like what do you guys do do you guys
just give them like a bus ticket like
out of prison or whatever or do you guys
like like what where where do you put
him at is there like a re-entry program
uh yes or no i mean
no in the sense that this is still so
far off that we can't really we can't
really figure out we don't even know who
will make the decision to bring you back
i mean will it be our organization will
it be some kind of you know uh
ethics panel of universities or a
government thing we don't we don't even
know that right so we can't really plan
in too much detail but yes we do think
about it and we it's part of our mission
statement you go to the website look at
our mission statement part of that is
not just to wake you up kind of shove
you out the door and say good luck man
no we're going to actually rehabilitate
you yeah here's a hand warmer yeah
exactly uh yeah when today think about
it today there are people who've been in
comas for years even decades uh if you
have seen the movie awakenings with
robert de niro i just watched that movie
a couple of months ago can we bring some
of that up
that's fascinating yeah based on on on
the book by oliver sex so these were
people who were basically uh in a
special kind of coma basically their
dopamine levels in the brain were really
low they were like frozen statues not
really aware of the passage of time some
of them like that for more than more
than a decade or two and when they were
woken up um of course for some of them
it was pretty horrifying because they
suddenly aged overnight uh yeah so like
that in our case would be the opposite
of that uh of course you look in the
mirror and go damn i look good yeah
right because
people would be excited because you
would be bringing them back in so what
you're saying is you're going to be
bringing people back into their best
self exactly because that's technology
that'll help because you'll come back
not feeling crappy like when you when
you cease to function you'll come back
feeling the best self plus we are there
to help you out we're going to
rehabilitate whatever that will mean at
the time it might mean um you know we're
going to put you in some virtual reality
environment to sort of train how the
world works before you step out in front
of that flying car or whatever you know
uh we don't really know what things
would be like 100 years from now nobody
does anybody who says they do is lying
because you just can't forecast that far
ahead except yeah future people if
somebody says they're from the future
brother probably lying
um
wow man so yeah you really your work
kind of like
like you know what you do but it's also
what you do is constantly like
gonna be evolving so
it's kind of interesting it's like your
job is um
like kind of uh
your job is kind of
tran it's like
it's malleable really because you we
don't know what the future holds it's
difficult it's about because we don't
know what the future is going to be
exactly and we get a better idea over
time um i mean it's also changes because
of the conditions under which we can do
our job so for instance it's only in the
last few years in this country that we
could use the death with dignity laws
which are actually very useful for us um
so yeah before that basically we had to
wait until our doctor declared illegally
dead that could have happened you know
out of the blue no warning but today
we've done this twice so far a member
can call us up and say look you know my
doctor said i've got no more than six
months to go i'm in a state that allows
the death with dignity laws i want to go
two weeks from wednesday no
so we can say okay great we're going to
have a team there so we don't have to
worry about getting someone there you
know get an emergency call we've got to
get someone there the person's already
stopped breathing no we can have a team
right there they can take their
medication they have to self-administer
our law uh we wait as soon as they're
declared legally dead we begin with no
delay whatsoever that's that's pretty
much ideal that's fresh and that's not
every state right now that's only
certain california can do that in a few
other states can arizona do that not yet
no they should be soon arizona arizona's
they're pretty wild west out there in a
lot of ways yeah we're kind of we're
kind of advanced in some ways a little
bit with another yeah it's a good call i
used to live in tucson over there and a
lot of people don't have shirt sleeves
on a lot of times
and uh we have you know we have
marijuana's legal there or it's not in
some other places but uh we're a little
conservative on some of the social stuff
like that would dignity but i think it's
mixed there so i think it will get there
but we do have teams here in california
so that's not really a big problem
so
so you have the okay so
people get
brought people sign up in advance yeah
almost always and do you meet with them
usually at least probably have zooms
with them or people are just like i want
the program this is it
uh
quite often they'll come for a visit and
we do encourage that because i mean you
don't have to because there's so many
videos you can go online and see what we
do but we do encourage people to come
and visit uh you know we give tours of
the place we're very open so we want
people to
see what the reality of it is oh yeah
but they don't have to come visit if
they've read a lot about it i went to
that coors brewing over there in golden
colorado you ever been to that no but
they have some similar containers to
ours they're the very big containers
like the viewers basically the vacuum
containers i think for brewing yeah
that's what i was thinking of if they're
full body you store them up and down or
can you do a lay down option no we don't
delay that that'd be kind of inefficient
for space that's an interesting question
because um
the first clients organization in china
started a few years ago and they were
talking to them and that's what they
wanted to do because it's kind of a
cultural thing
they want to lay that you can't stack
them though because that applies
superiority if you're on top i guess so
they want to do that but it just it just
doesn't work very well it doesn't work
very well in the vessels it's expensive
nothing from china works very well i
don't think no i agree
so now they're actually uh we actually
store patients upside down in the whole
body patients wow i don't think we
really need to do that um
basically the idea was that the liquid
nitrogen will boil off over time it will
gradually get lower and lower over a
period of weeks to months and if you
have a little bit at the bottom
obviously that's where you want the
brain to be at the bottom the last thing
to get warmed up although that shouldn't
have happened so they're upside down
yeah
but it's not really necessary today
because we now store patients in inside
these steel steel containers you can see
there's an aluminum pod that contains
the patient and that conducts
temperature really well so even if you
just got a little bit of liquid nitrogen
at the bottom it's still going to be
super cold at the top but it's just kind
of an extra uh you know extra layers
what do they call it shoot uh laces and
what is this for the phrase basically
shooting fish in a barrel no no uh the
back up option with the lease isn't the
straight off i forget what you know what
i mean we we just do that as an extra uh
protection an extra layer yeah
um and who's this chick she's not sorry
i meant suspenders and belts but built
in suspenders oh yeah if you go building
suspenders that's insane that is that's
a starbucks from battlestar galactica is
it really on many other shows dang i
gotta quit going to coffee bean then we
had a really good time talking that was
a good that was a good tour i bet but
enthusiastic about it she seems and she
seemed like a nice lady yeah but i'll
say this so
dude this is first of all this is crazy
man first of all thank you so much for
coming in man this is really fascinating
because
i don't want to die to be honest with
you you know that death is boring i mean
who wants to die it's just boring yeah
well part of it starts to feel good
because you want to get some rest i
think but there's a big other part of it
it's like
but you know i don't want that much rest
yeah so what i'm thinking is like i
would love to be able to come back one
day you know or have the option and so
what kind of that's the thing though
it's an option right you don't right you
don't have to live forever we're not and
that's that's something because i think
you mentioned that early on we're not
offering eternity we're not offering
immortality because we can't do that you
can still get hit by a bus or get shot
by somebody or an asteroid can land on
your head this is not about immortality
we're not offering that we're afraid the
chance to come back and live for who
knows how long hundreds thousands of
years but you know after 500 years you
go you know i think i've done everything
i want to do you could always check out
so it's an option that's the that's
already the point of it
do would you ever worry that you would
bring people back
and wherever they've gone when they've
left here like hypothetically left here
was so awesome they're gonna be like ah
[ __ ] dude you brought me back here back
here to hardee's or whatever
uh
i'm not really worried about that um
i have to distinguish my own personal
opinion from that of the organization
right the organization doesn't take any
any view on whether there's a soul or
not uh i personally don't believe in a
soul i don't i think that we're just a
physical being and if you destroy that
you're gone and uh so long as we can
restore it you can come back but uh if
there is a soul and you know i've taught
philosophy of religion i thought it made
sense mary's not too far from borrow
state oh really yeah oh that's awesome
man so yeah i've taught philosophy
religion and i know i understand that
probably better than many of the
religious people do i found i do know
that you're a philosopher and a doctor i
do know those things so i don't you
think i don't know anything
so i don't think it's a problem and for
several reasons let's look at uh we
mentioned uh in uh vitro fertilization
what used to be called test tube babies
right uh they're frozen my girlfriend's
eggs are frozen yeah frozen embryos it
could be there for years sometimes more
than a decade well if you believe that
the soul enters at the point of
conception they have souls
and yet do you ever uh you know of the
millions of people walking around today
who used to be in that state did they
ever say yeah it was really boring you
know floating around getting really
bored no they never report that so it
doesn't seem to be a problem for that
yeah we also have people who've been
legally dead for up to an hour or so and
if you believe the soul leaves when the
body stops functioning uh again they
don't really report you know being in
kind of boring condition so i don't
think it's a problem also because if
there is a soul it's obviously not a
physical thing because otherwise we
could detect it with science so it must
be outside space and time so i think
whether it's a day or you know a minute
or a day or 100 years shouldn't make any
difference right that's true if it's
gone for an hour it's gone for it if
it's that attached to the actual
physical being then it should be able to
come back so
really you guys
if people are able to be
thawed out
hypothetically back into existence
we might find we would learn a lot about
if there are souls or not
maybe yeah i mean my view is it's
completely compatible with just about
any religion there might be one or two
exceptions that uh is it the jehovah's
witnesses or one of the groups that
doesn't do blood transfusions that could
be a problem for us removing the blood
but apart from that i mean if you're a
christian uh it would seem to me that
you'd want to do this because first of
all why are you in such a a rush to get
to your eternal reward don't you want to
do some more good works or save some
souls that kind of thing yeah it's a bit
selfish to take off at the earliest
opportunity right yeah buzz out yeah you
have one stroke and then you leave
that's kind of soft and uh judaism too i
think is actually very pro uh pro living
and uh you know life is basically good
you stick around and do good works oh
yeah my jewish buddies they'll mill
around forever dude if there's some
opportunity you know jews love to do
stuff and create you know be part of
things for sure so so it's really just
going to lose them no it's i mean the
way i think of it is chronics is really
an extension of emergency medicine it's
not some kind of strange thing about
dead people because they're not really
dead it's just an extension of emergency
medicine it's a doctor saying i just
can't do anything more for this person
right now and we're saying well let's
not just destroy them by putting them in
an oven or the ground give them to us
let us treat them stop them getting
worse and give the future a chance of
giving them more life that seems like
the reason the more conservative thing
to do
yeah it seems like
yeah i mean i consider myself a
christian and i believe that i'm down
for it you know
um yeah do you feel like it's like
do you feel like it's like divinely
intend like there's divine intention
behind this or do you think that
it would be like divinely frowned upon i
guess and you may have already just
answered that well i don't i don't think
either if there is a god out there uh i
don't see god objecting to us uh
creating the internet for instance or uh
electric vehicles or even old-fashioned
vehicles so i think if there is a god
then for the most part that god lets us
use our own intelligence our god-given
intelligence if you like yeah um
and what we do it is up to us and what
we do hopefully we'll do good things
with it but i don't think there is a
list of things that we we mustn't do
it's more a matter of you know let's do
the right thing let's do good things
this is a good thing this is about
saving lives about giving people more
life and unable to do more good things
yeah and maybe god would be impressed
too god would be like dang you guys
figured this out yeah i think that'd be
pretty cool too you got off the planet
in 1969 leonard saw on the moon now
you've bringing people back to that's
pretty cool you guys are doing good guys
yeah
i want to tell you
that your body has a wiener on it
and sometimes it isn't working as well
as you'd like because of different
things
well blue chew
can help it's a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable form chewable chewable
and at a fraction of the cost
blue chews tablets
combat all forms of ed
that's right erectile dysfunction
and they can help men gain extra
confidence for when it's time to perform
when it's that showdown for the weiner
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days the best
part it's all done online
and here's a special deal for you who
want to chew your way
to a well weiner
try blue chew free when you use our
promo code th eo at checkout just pay
five dollars shipping that's
bluechew.com
promo code theo to receive your first
month for free
and are you austrian
no
i ask you no no i'm not austrian oh yeah
yeah oh yeah that would be uh
schwarzenegger huh no i'm from england
actually i've been uh
i should pull this back in the history
okay i'm from england um i've been in
the state since 1987. oh i couldn't tell
if you were from england if you had a
cold
well yeah kind of a little both so uh i
came over actually because of cryonics
in a way actually first came over in
1986 to california because uh i joined
alcoa i was 22 years old at the time
and
i i came over here because i sent a
little donation like out of my puny
student salary i had a tiny donation
because alcohol was a tiny little
organization at the time and how did you
hear about it
um i heard about it
oh well is it long and a short version
of that uh i heard about it initially as
a fictional thing in a kid's tv show
which kind of still amazes me because
this was a like a young kids tv show
with some pretty interesting advanced
ideas in the very first one it's called
time slip you can actually get it on dvd
now which i did about 10 years ago
in the first episode they go through
this kind of hole in space and time uh
some years into the future to this
arctic research station
and the episode that the the caption of
the station had been you know seriously
injured and so he was cryo preserved wow
and they looked at his frosty face whoa
it also had artificial intelligence it
had brain augmentation this was a kids
show it's like amazing
uh so that was a fictional thing and
then later on i read a book by robert
anton wilson i know if you know this guy
from the 70s used to be editor for
penthouse he wrote the illuminatus
trilogy it was a big counterculture uh
book back then uh he in his non-fiction
book cosmic trigger he wrote about uh
his daughter luna who'd been murdered at
the age of 14 in san francisco and he
had a you know terror when he had a
brain cryo preserved i went oh so this
is a real thing so that's when you
learned out that that the thing you had
seen in like a fictional aspect as a
child was now real that was the first
time i saw it was real and so you sent
him in some money you're like i'm sorry
this is my church before that i was uh i
didn't know anybody you know actually
doing it though so
the next thing happened i was you know i
was kind of a strange person in the
sense because i was interested in all
these weird futuristic ideas and nobody
else around me was and then i saw an ad
for group meeting at imperial college in
london to talk about space colonization
and life extension and all the kind of
cool things i was into so i went down
there and at that time they had the
magazine we still produced today
cryonics magazine and they shoved it at
me and said what do you think of this i
said yeah that makes sense to me so
that's how i first heard of it and then
i got involved with the organization i
joined up so i came over to the states
in 86 for six weeks
i signed up i did my training i actually
went to ucla with jerry leaf who was a
surgery researcher there um alcor at the
time was actually in fullerton just
before they moved to riverside which is
a not quite good place to be yeah a lot
of bangers out there dog
at least ms9 out there we had legal
problems we could talk about that yeah
all these guys do too trust me yeah no
that's not quite the same kind maybe but
no with the bureaucrats oh you did yeah
so so you guys are trying to establish
are you you're joining something that's
already established after you're on a
six week is it like a camp or something
like no it was just i decided to come
over well basically what happened was
the president at the time said okay you
send us some money that's that's great
i'm gonna challenge you why don't you
actually sign up become the first member
in england i said okay i'll do that they
said if you've got the balls for that
why don't you actually start something
in england we ended up actually creating
the first cryonics organization in
england at the time and did a lot of a
lot of media appearances i did this very
scary thing i'd never been on tv i was
on the terry wogan show which is like
johnny carson used to be everybody
watched it it was live terry logan bring
up a picture of terry logan let's see
what we're looking at here i always want
to see this very famous presenter in
england
the biggest show live so i had to go on
stage live in front of millions of
people like no experience terrifying
there you zoom in on a pickup and let me
get a look at this guy terry wogan yeah
he looks like that he's around forever
he looks exactly like you'd expect him
to look irish irish fella oh is he irish
irish were you cheerful oh that's
unfortunate well he was a good host
but actually that was actually a good
appearance because uh i was on the very
i had the other guests were on i sat
next to the makeup room to shirley
bassey you remember the bond singer she
did all the james bond themes in the in
the sean connery days i've remembered
forever
the song yeah i remember wow that was
her so she was in the chat because i was
there for like a minute she was there
for pretty good she's cute
yeah i don't think i could really see
her because she was kind of to my side
yeah
but then on the actual show they had um
that's crazy so they just have you so
that had to feel kind of strange or at
this point were you feeling kind of like
empowered then like what have i stepped
into i was kind of terrified at that
point i mean i got used to it fairly
quickly but it was kind of scary scary
for the very it's actually my second
appearance the first one was two days
early on what they call breakfast tv at
the time because it was a new thing but
actually for the woken show i guess they
had a budget in those days i was in
bristol and they sent the guy on the
train all the way to bristol to talk to
me to make sure i wasn't a crazy person
i guess wow um but on the show itself
they had um oh what is his name
james burke he was like a a science
boffin who did all these very popular
shows had a show called connections
which is amazing it showed how all these
developments and technology came out of
totally unexpected directions and it was
a really good show and he stayed on next
to me he was that guy before me and i
was like oh [ __ ] what's he going to say
is he going to say this is stupid and he
said two things both of which were
supportive so i went oh phew that's
great
wow
almost accepted at that point yeah like
a moment of like oh here's some
acceptance by kind of just society um so
then i came over to the state spent six
weeks here basically doing the training
went back and then the next year uh i
decided i moved over here to go to usc
to do my my doctoral work so i helped
out with alcohol doing cases back those
in those early days and then eventually
went on to run the organization much
later and at that point are you guys
like going to bars when people are like
are you how are you at how are you
advertising going to buzz how are you
reaching people you know um or people
that buy motorcycles because i'll say
this
um
that's an interesting floor people that
buy motorcyclists are the number one
organ donors a lot of people don't know
that but um yeah i've heard that my plus
they're probably adventurous in spirit
right yeah yeah and they i mean yeah
they're the number one organ donors but
anyway so so how are you guys
advertising like and and getting the
word out to people that there's this
company i'm still thinking about you
saying bars i think i think about going
into a bar it's like hey can i buy you a
pint and talk to you about getting your
brain frozen
i'm not sure that would work that well
i don't know there's some chicks i think
it would work on
any gay dude would take that as a good
you could say anything to a gay dude if
he's interested he'll he'll be
interested so i think he could buy them
anything you know
yeah but the biker thing is interesting
because uh actually yeah it's
interesting because how do you find
people i mean our members tend to be
pretty well educated because you need to
sort of understand a bit about the
process and understand how it could work
and the future stuff but i think very
important again is this adventurous
personality and how do you find that
combination maybe mountain climbers
maybe people like to travel the world oh
yeah maybe bikers i don't know
yeah no it's interesting well you said
earlier these are adventurers you know
it's people that are explorers you know
yeah i mean explorers of tomorrow yeah
well people what's that from
me
i'm just doing the voice like for him i
don't know if like a seth mcfarlane
voice or something yeah no it makes you
feel like that it's like well i'd never
thought before until you and i are
sitting here talking
first of all
could i come back that's all i that's as
far as my brain it would go going with
it wow if they could do this sure i'd be
willing to be a part you know i'd be
willing this sounds like it'd be up my
alley but then would i want to you know
would you want to just walk out into
like you know back out into life not
knowing who would be there what it would
be like what if we were under like rule
of another you know you just don't know
what it would be like well okay so i've
said before that you know i nobody can
forecast the future not in detail right
we have no idea but i think we can
reasonably safely make some general
predictions okay general trend
prediction so you say we have no idea
what i think we have some idea of what
it'd be like and i'm going to say things
here which a lot of people are listening
and go nah that's [ __ ] man because
everybody today is thinking that the
future is really screwed up can i say f
words here yeah you can say everybody's
saying that the future is [ __ ] right
we're going to be [ __ ] by the ais
we're going to be [ __ ] by pandemics
there's going to be mad max worlds
there's just going to be all kinds of
awful stuff because that's what science
fiction shows because that's the easy
way to write drama right yeah i think
that's the wrong way to look at things
if you think about human history over
the very long term
have things got better or worse well
obviously they've gotten better because
we just go back a little way women
didn't have the vote black people were
enslaved we didn't have painkillers we
didn't have antibiotics we didn't have
anything
a lot of people couldn't keep their
teeth for a long time teeth right
exactly in fact in england we'd have bad
teeth just a few decades ago you guys
are still practicing yeah he's still
working on that one um so you know so i
often ask people that how let me go take
it back 100 years 200 years 500 years a
thousand years would you want to live
then hell no when you actually think
about what it's like it was horrible it
was also very violent i mean people
think it's violent today they have no
idea things have gotten we're actually
at the least violent time in human
history even the bible at one point cain
killed abel there were four people in
the bible and one of them killed the
other one yeah well god says in the old
testament quite a few times wipe out
this village
wipe out all of them or else sometimes
he says keep the women from yourselves
but sometimes you just wipe out
everybody so it was it was pretty brutal
back then yeah it sounds like it so so
my view is that i hated that the
reasonable way to think about the future
is to extrapolate what we've always been
doing right almost like the standard
like the s p 500 yeah we get better over
time there are a few and again a lot of
people don't believe this but go look
there's a great website called our world
in data if you don't believe me our
world and data will in data in our world
yeah or humanprogress.org both of them
will show you in immense detail and all
these charts uh yeah how many people are
starving to death it's going down
actually in total not just
proportionately um so that gives you
this actual data so instead of when
somebody's like man everything sucks man
you know these actually have lots and
lots of information showing how things
are generally getting better obviously
there are local problems things get
worse and locally for in various ways oh
yeah um but overall there are a few
people starving not just proportionally
but in total uh though a lot of people
think pollution is getting worse even
smart people i was debating this
professor at ucla um on a is actually an
oxford union debate and i was telling
you you know the air in los angeles has
gotten better over a decade she went no
it hasn't no it hasn't
really how could you not know that just
look at pictures from the 60s you
couldn't see it was like london fog yeah
right we had lead in the air we had all
kinds of volatile kind of competitions
nope smoke in the air too more probably
yeah about that as well but no you're
saying so that's a great place to get
information like yeah even joe rogan
says that sometimes sometimes i
romanticize things and i'm like man i
missed this and i missed that and he
goes you would have hated that he's like
you're right now is really the best you
know the best time to be alive you have
the best chance of living you have
option to as much information as you
want
yeah i mean go back a couple hundred
years you probably never went more than
20 miles from where you were born that
was that was where you lived you did the
damn job your dad and grandfather did i
mean you had no choices if you were gay
you're in big trouble yeah yeah you're
hiding yeah gay people had to hide all
the time if you had the wrong religious
ideas you're in big trouble you couldn't
even get away witches remember they had
witches oh yeah like 130 years ago they
had witches somewhere dude they got them
yeah that stuff's crazy man um so yeah
so i think it's reasonably safe i mean
it's always possible to completely screw
things up and just destroy ourselves but
um i love your attitude the most likely
thing is that we'll be pretty decent
place to come back in it'll probably be
better than it is today so i'm willing
to come back even if i have nothing and
i do have plans to actually have
something but if i have nothing i still
want to do it i want to come back and
enjoy my life yeah because if you come
back and it sucks you can always leave
again exactly
there are ways excuse me there are ways
of actually coming back with something
we hope um first of all as an
organization because we're a non-profit
we we have a we have what we call a
patient care trust fund where when you
pay for this procedure a big chunk of
that money is put into a separate fund
and is managed by its own board of
trustees it can't be used to pay for
anything else just for keeping your
crowd preserved and eventually revived
um but beyond so we can't divide that up
because it's a non-profit but you can
personally set up a special trust fund
an asset preservation trend uh asset
preservation fund where uh it'll be
managed by trustees after you're legally
dead and when you come back if this
works out then you should get that money
back it's kind of like a like a
university endowment i guess or
something like that where you can tie it
up for a long period of time so
hopefully when you come back you'll have
money because we don't even know if you
need money yeah maybe the robots will be
doing all the main things you you only
have to pay for really expensive stuff
like going into space or something we
don't really know but it's nice to have
that option and so the cost when people
want to sign up for this type of service
you know what what does that cost and
how does that look how do you
what is that like yeah it's less than
people think um i mean i signed up as a
pretty poor student when i was 22 years
old in england
but uh yeah our costs have gone up a bit
bit since then because it was all
volunteer and now we have you know
professional organization but basically
there are two expenses there is the
membership the membership dues which you
pay while you're still legally alive it
keeps the organization functioning um
and that uh that actually depends on age
now but let's say it's around uh about
600 a year so yeah if you're someone who
goes to starbucks every day and gets a
cup of coffee don't tell me you can't
afford that right
yeah if you can afford to get a little
buzz in the morning you can get four to
get a little buzz forever yeah if it's a
fraction of that price so so it's really
not that much and then um the one that
will seem expensive is that the fee
itself we'll call the cryo preservation
fee which pays for the entire process
that i've described everything from us
sending a team to stand by your bedroom
even for days to weeks doing that whole
procedure taking you to alcohol in
arizona doing the surgery the perfusion
the cool down and the indefinite storage
all of that for a whole body is a
minimum of 200 000 and for neuro just
the brain is eighty thousand oh wow now
that may seem like a fair bit to people
but i make the point almost all that
matters probably 95 of our members pay
for that with life insurance so you
don't have to have 80 000 or 200 000
bucks in your pocket you have a life
insurance policy which most people can
have and if you're reasonably young and
healthy that's not a big expense
so so people make our organization the
beneficiary of make sure organization
the beneficiary of the life insurance
policy wow that's really interesting and
can people even say they have enough
money in their life insurance policy
they could split that up and make their
family and you guys absolutely wow
[Music]
dang so
dude i think i want to get in bro i
can't even believe i didn't think i was
going to buy in but i think dude
business in arizona yeah it's like
all-time share it's like it's like the
ultimate time share you know and a lot
of times here's their [ __ ] my brother
got him one but um but this is like the
time share like that this is like the
real time share
like if i'm buying a time share i feel
like you guys are like selling the best
one you know
um
so you wouldn't have to share your body
with anybody
yeah could you share one of the little
things with somebody well actually yeah
the viewers the containers yeah actually
that is what you do right now because
good uh the the the ones we've been
using for a long time contain four
patients four whole body patients but
now we have what we call the superduos
which will take about 11 whole body
patients hell yeah you might say well
who am i going to be spending my time
next day well you won't be aware of
anything of course there's no
consciousness do you ever see the movie
uh vanilla sky tom cruise and penelope
cruz
yeah i did see you yeah so that was very
unrealistic cryonics right they had
cryonics in that but they offered a um
a lucid dreaming option where you could
have dreams while you're crying preserve
that does not work you cannot do that
because there's no brain activity
there's no metabolism so you guys don't
have that but that doesn't work but what
about the one movie with uh mel gibson
that i loved remember when he came back
he was frozen oh is that one where he
ages rapidly when he comes back yeah see
that's kind of a negative one though
there's no reason why that would happen
that's gonna yeah sorry don't you don't
reference that one but i loved that
movie just because he got to come back
you know he got to come back and have
some moments that he missed out on
because he was from like 1940s or
something and yeah and he got to come
back there it was right there uh forever
young young right
there's demolition there's been so many
movies demolition man of course were
that's one of the reasons i was so
interested in speaking with you because
it's a it's
it is fascinating it's fascinating
because i still just think of my life on
these limited terms
and to be able to adjust my perspective
to think of my life as like
well what if this is just the start of
something that's going to happen like
it's just the start i mean if you've
been 50 years it's still just the start
that's the great thing is it changes
your perspective on things yeah and if
you think what kind of people would we
be i mean just think about how we are
right now
human condition is pretty awful in a way
because
you pretty stupid when you're 20 years
old even 30 years old you kind of
haven't learned very much right even 41.
yeah even 58 i mean yeah
it takes about 58. i'm 58. yeah i look
great man well thanks well i don't want
to get cry preserved any sooner than i
need to yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so yeah we it takes us a while to learn
things and just as we're starting to
figure a few things out in life we start
going wrinkly and weak getting heart
disease and our brain slows down that's
true isn't this awful that as age goes
up vitality goes down at the same time
what if you could live and definitely
get older in years but
stay vigorous and youthful in fact maybe
even get smarter because we could
probably do alterations to make you even
more intelligent and you know
emotionally emotionally more stable what
kind of person would you be after a few
hundred years of increasing experience
and wisdom i mean one thing i don't
think we'd have many wars because who
who fights the wars it's the 19 and 20
year olds it's not the people who are 70
years old they don't risk all that life
they've had so i think people would
think long term they think about the
environment they think about you know
not having wars but better kinds of ways
of negotiating so i think it really
changes a lot of stuff and i think for
the better
well yeah it's so true you're it's so
often like i always
i always uh
talk with guys about how how crazy it is
how hard it is to pass information on
from one generation to the next even
though they're right there it's like you
know it's
and how
like
how resi it doesn't feel successfully
residual when you like teach your kids
they learn the same thing you learned
and then you're dead you know it's like
it seems like we get caught in this like
just start this
this bad
repetition
uh it doesn't hurt when the schools are
so bad too and that's hard to get to
learn anything from
as i know from teaching yeah
um
but yeah to to have an extension where
you're like wow i'm going to be able to
really keep this information
are there are there certain like
ethnicities or
uh gender who who who does that who
who's your clientele right now kind of
or who has it been and what has that
looked like uh changing over time or not
changing of course we will take anybody
just like a hospital we're not going to
turn someone away because we don't like
the look of you or your your religion or
whatever right right but um yeah
we do tend to skew mail right now and
you know there's some uh discussion
about why is that that and you can have
kind of speculations well maybe it's an
evolutionary thing that traditionally
males have been the ones to the hunter
gatherers to go out there and get the
food while the women kind of protect
things at home or whatever maybe i don't
know that's kind of a possible
explanation yeah or that are a lot of
art types what is archetypes
yeah
a lot of our our our i think it's
archetypes have been like males that are
like the um
you know and so maybe they've been a lot
of the explorers over history and even
though now it's changing some like they
have like she-hulk is coming out i think
yeah but it's like
but so now i think maybe that process
might be getting more involved in
women's heads you know exactly so it's
changing but it's still i think there is
still that aspect there right so okay so
that might be that might be part of it
but we're seeing uh so we're like 70
something male right now but we're also
seeing more families signing up as a
whole which is great because the idea of
coming back with your family is
obviously more appealing than being solo
yeah so that's one aspect
we tend to find that our members tend to
be uh more highly educated than the
average and i think that's the natural
because to think about these ideas in
depth and to go through the details and
figure it out it's more likely to be
someone who's more educated yeah i never
thought i mean i hadn't thought much
about it it's not necessary um
but again
i guess in terms of
people's industry we definitely have a
lot of people from the computer industry
i think there's a reason why we have a
lot of people from computers which is
if you think about it people who deal
with computers
deal with really complex problems
millions of lines of code uh these
things most people look at go how the
heck are we gonna deal with this it's
impossible but they're used to hacking
the system hacking the problem right
they break it down into smaller
components and if you think about the
body and the aging body and repairing
the brain that's a massively complex
problem most people gonna say oh that's
impossible but someone who deals with
computers can say no it's not we're just
gonna break it down into smaller
components we're gonna hack the problem
until we've solved it so i think it's
pretty natural that we get people from
that area in particular
and that's so interesting
i'm glad those people are going we're
going to need those people and what if
they're ethnicities is it more is it
like a or i guess wealthier people can
maybe afford it but
especially when you say that life
insurance can be part of it that's a
huge i mean that makes a big difference
yeah because
do you want to leave especially if you
got like kind of a shitty kid do you
want to leave your money to your shitty
kid dude who's not doing much who's
doing a lot of you know
you know uh who's still playing like a
lot of like pickup sports or whatever
and he's like 45 he's living at the
house and whatever but or do you want to
yeah get a job and i'm going to get and
i'm going to come back and make sure you
have a job
that's interesting man yeah but no as
you said earlier
we do encourage people to provide for
their family as well because if you
don't if you put everything into the
crowd preservation fund there's an
incentive for i mean it's amazing how
bad families are when once you once
you're legally dead they turn into
vultures in many cases it's pretty sad
and you say oh no my family would never
do that well man we've seen it too often
they'll actually try and take the funds
you've dedicated for you know your own
possible survival really have you guys
had to go to any court cases
yes we have a number of times and we
will do that we were very we're absolute
about protecting our members rights so
we've had par you know relatives try to
take people out of crowd preservation
try to block it and we we have we've
become the court a number of times to
protect the rights so try to provide for
them you know separately unless you
really hate the kid and don't want to do
it but uh
but yeah provide for them separately um
preferably with a separate policy to
make it even less complicated i love
matt this is cool man and why why um how
do we know that you guys will
uh
be able to stay around like
i guess we don't great question i
actually uh you know i take that
question very seriously um people are
really interested go to a website
alcor.org go to the cryonics magazine
and look for a two-part article i wrote
on this very topic uh how what was the
title how to sustain an organization for
more than a century and we'll put a link
in that in the um in the episode we'll
put it in the set information guys but
yeah it's just because yeah i guess that
would be some people's question because
even like i remember we went to pizza
when i was young pizza i don't know if
they have it in your country but they
have a place here it's called pizza hut
and uh
when i was young it was like a nice
sit-down restaurant we'd go in there
people were nice and now it's like
barely even you know it's not as good
anymore and there's just like a bunch of
brothers fighting outside all the time
your country like england is mine
all of england is mine
i'm actually more american than english
at this point so i've been here since do
you feel that way yeah yeah we've i
think we've had three british people and
we've had you
uh michael bisping
and robbie williams i think are free
three brits pretty cool
pretty cool uh client pretty cool
group
but so yeah so anyway sorry to go back
to yeah i'm sorry no i almost lost the
machine i thought too
so no um so i've written on this because
it's a really important topic and and
it's a reasonable concern if you look at
most companies they don't tend to last
that long it's a little tricky if you
look at the numbers because they often
merge they don't necessarily die they
can emerge into other companies right
but still most for-profit companies uh
you can think of exceptions but most of
them don't last more than a few decades
and small businesses don't last more
than a few years at all in general uh so
yeah we i did some research on that what
you find is the most of the really
long-lived organizations in history tend
to be either religious organizations
governmental institutions or educational
institutions now there are exceptions in
japan they have they actually have a
number of thousand-year plus companies
and they're almost all very tightly held
family-run businesses
uh i think that the longest live one was
like one thousand four hundred and
something years old
uh and it i think it built temples or
something and then during some massive
war there were no temples to build they
built uh coffins for a while instead so
it's a little bit flexible
but generally you know obviously i i
went for instance i went to oxford
university which is the second oldest
university in the world yeah i walked
over there one time walked by it it's
cool do you see the gardens yeah it's
beautiful dude blew my mind well that's
been around for like half a millennium
so that's a long time right
um i think the oldest one is you know
these civil in spain so they can survive
a long time obviously religion the
vatican's been around for a long time
other religious organizations yeah um so
non-profits kind of
the things about
you know for-profit companies which i'm
you know perfectly fine with but they
have to especially public ones they have
to answer shareholders and they think
about short-term profits and so on if
you're really long-term you really want
to be a non-profit because you don't
have to worry about short you have to
make money you have to make more than
you you spend obviously just because
your non-profit doesn't mean you can
lose money right you go out of existence
right but you don't have to have like
you don't have to meet certain huge
goals you don't have to uh appease uh
shareholders you can just be you know do
your best and stay alive yeah you can
you can optimize for the long term
rather than the short term and you guys
are almost like a school and a bit of a
religion in a way that
i wouldn't want to say that but uh only
in the sense that or a bit of a belief
that people want to be explore yeah
that's what i mean what do you say we're
thinking about some pretty profound
stuff in that in that sense yeah that's
a good point yeah uh but we do there's
all kinds of things we do to survive at
the long term and some of this is unique
to us so i mentioned earlier the patient
care trust fund when you when you pay
the fee for this a big chunk of it goes
into a separate fund that can't be
touched for any operations only for
maintaining patients and that is
maintained by a separate board of
trustees there's a strict rule you can
never draw more than two percent a year
so even if the market is crappy for a
long period of time we can write that
out
um we have an endowment fund just like
universities which is fairly modest
right now it's just a few million but
hopefully that'll build up and that will
pay uh you know a steady income to the
operations uh we have a board of
directors that they're not not paid uh
it's kind of self-perpetuating so they
can't be voted out by people who are
hostile which can happen in in small oh
yeah totally get voted out by outsiders
uh we do a lot of different things to
really protect ourselves for the long
term and you know we're in our 51st year
right now so we've been around for over
half a century as it is at this point
that's incredible
yeah it's really really it's just man
the whole thing is really interesting to
me so once you so how would we bring
people back i think that's got to be the
big question now
yeah actually what's going to happen
there maxie
what are we doing okay the time has come
you guys get the email from whoever it
is
uh you know neil degrasse tyson or
whatever emails you and tells you hey
maxie we got everybody let's bring them
out you know let's do a big thaw or
whatever let's cook you know let's do a
barbecue you know well the opposite of a
perfect well what about yeah let's do it
a slow roast
okay what happens how do we do it max uh
i don't know is i don't know is the
first answer right because again we
can't forecast specific technologies in
the future i'll do a little bit better
than a second but just to make the point
that it'd be kind of like asking me
let's say we're in 1890 and you said
okay max how are we going to put someone
on the moon and when it's like how the
hell do i know that i've got to invent
rockets that we haven't designed yet
life support systems computer systems
now we know it's possible in principle
it doesn't violate any physical law and
that's the point that we're making
there's nothing impossible about this
but how do i know exactly how i don't
but given that okay uh we can point to a
number of lines of evidence first of all
i already mentioned we're growing organs
in the lab so we can actually get
control of human biology more and more
and we should better regenerate organs
and tissues and that's that'll be a big
thing in the in the coming years people
regrowing organs of course i mean that's
a that's
if they can do that if they can regrow
tissue that's a huge part of you guys
deal yeah that's a huge part of it
they're making pigs back they're
bringing big pigs back right and but the
most critical thing of course is
repairing the brain that's the most
important part that's where we live
so for that we may need well visible
there may be a point where we get so
good at preserving people that we do
very little damage now that means we can
bring people back with much less
advanced technology but for our existing
patients where there is considerable
damage there's often some ice formation
that we haven't entirely prevented oh
yeah there's all kinds of damage that's
gonna take some advanced technology
probably nanotechnology i don't know if
you're familiar with nanotechnology um
it's it's something that you know here
people hear the word a lot but don't
understand very well i just saw earlier
the other day about how they were using
dna to go inside of a body to detect
something
um
they made a nanotechnology out of dna
and we're using it inside it's kind of a
biological form of
then becomes a different form so
nanotechnology can be the biological
form like you're talking about or it
could be more of a mechanical form
basically the definition of it is it's
from the nanoprefix meaning a billionth
billionth of a meter okay so you've got
you know meter length objects you've got
things that are you know one micrometers
incredibly tiny tiny machines people
have built actually a functioning
automobile that you have to have a
microscope to see it's so small and
we're talking about a thousand times
smaller than that so devices that uh you
know we've evolved these devices
naturally obviously they're inside our
cells but we're talking about actually
designing devices that google inside
your cells we go right here um yeah now
about throwing for your body there you
go so uh they could be artificial blood
cells so you could actually uh robert
freitas who's an expert in this area
designed what do you call respirocytes
where you could pump in all this extra
oxygen you wouldn't you could hold your
breath for like an hour or something wow
because the nanobots will be able to
carry out oxygen with them it's a very
simple example but you can actually
devices that go in there could find uh
you know deposits of fat in the arteries
and slice that off go inside cells cut
out all the cancer very specifically
take out the plaques that might be
causing alzheimer's disease uh repair
age-related damage so basically this is
like a very advanced technology which is
on the drawing board and uh fetus has
actually a book on on this right now
that we know it's possible because it
doesn't violate physical laws it's not
like time travel it's just a matter of
developing it right it's the same thing
that goes back to when you said well how
would we get to the moon from somebody
in the 1890s or whatever and like well
somebody who could look ahead at that
point and say
it's possible because it doesn't getting
there wouldn't really defy any physical
laws but not everybody got that point i
mean right no of course not no i'm sure
if you told me i'd have been like you're
out of here like the new york times this
is this is hilarious the new york times
in the i think it was the
late 40s or the 50s maybe uh they they
kind of dismissed the idea of space
travel because there's always you can't
move in space because there's nothing to
push against it's like
do not understand newton's laws of
action and reaction so that was pretty
stupid the british astronomer royal a
guy you know is a yes physics in 1959 10
years before he landed on the moon says
that this is ideas ludicrous we'll never
we'll never fly in space without what's
wrong this is the astronomer royal so
when people say that something's
impossible
always ask them you know why do you
think it's impossible because people if
they can't imagine something they think
it's impossible which is pretty poor
argument right just because their lack
of imagination doesn't mean it's not
possible and that usually is it's
usually lack of imagination argument
from lack of imagination they need to
better show that it actually violates
physical laws like right now as far as
we can tell given basic physics we're
never going to have backwards time
travel you cannot forge time travel by
going very fast towards the speed of
light and you know your zone of
reference changes and so if you came if
you want to get out of my marriage or
whatever but you know but you can't go
back in time as far as we can tell that
probably isn't possible so but we're not
talking about violating physical laws
we're talking about what we're already
seeing which is the development of
science and technology the way it
inevitably keeps developing on a finer
and finer level just a projection of
that
how long it will take we can't really
say i'm guessing 50 to 150 years very
vaguely
but it seems like a good bet
right it's i'm look there's nothing to
lose basically yeah the most i work i do
my bookies sometimes but for me this
legitimately seems like a good bet it's
like
it just costs a little bit but what you
know it's not that crazy if you're dead
what are you gonna do with the money
anyway and it's that's not that yes it's
a lot of money
but when people are buying a lot of the
[ __ ] that they're buying these days it's
not that it's not that unrealistic and
then also if you got to come back and if
you didn't like some people and they
didn't do it then they wouldn't be there
which would be cool right but what about
this i'll live your enemies yeah outlive
your enemies right yeah but what about
the brain so what would have to happen
with the brain because
or what
what's happening now with the with the
thawing out that or the freezing what's
happening with the cells that's not
there yet a hundred percent
uh
well like i said with a lot of tissues
we can we can actually uh cryopreserve
them bring them back perfectly well
the problem is as i kind of mentioned
earlier the biggest problem right now is
in reversing the process is the larger
the tissue the larger the massive tissue
um the harder it is to bring them back
because the problem is actually this the
rate of re-warming you can cool very
slowly but you have to rewarm very
rapidly and i won't get too much into
the technical details but it might sound
weird kind of flash for i am it's kind
of yes in a way well the problem is the
ice can actually form as you warm up
which might sound weird how could ice
form as you warm up but it actually can
it's called recrystallization
and uh to avoid that you have to rewarm
very rapidly it could be like several
degrees per second and for you know like
skin which is thin you can do that right
um even heart valves and corneas but
when you're talking like a kidney or a
brain or a whole organism that's pretty
tricky and so there's a research into
this right now there's all kinds of
different ways of doing that but right
now we can't do it fast enough that's
why we can't bring people back today so
people will say well what you're saying
is stupid because have you ever brought
anybody back well no of course we
haven't that's not the point right and
we don't have to today right because
when you cry preserve you can wait for
as long as it takes you're not getting
any worse
yeah
dude so you almost need something that's
going to be able to reheat the center
and the outside at the exact same kind
of rate kind of yeah
there's all kinds of actually just to
the conference we had recently i had a
top researcher who talked about some of
the main methodologies of radio
frequency warming and nanowarming
there's all kinds of methods that are
being investigated today
do you believe so you must obviously
believe in that whether we have so much
more
uh
to learn
oh i don't know
we're just getting started i mean people
people often in history is funny if you
look back at some history books you find
people saying that we've we've learned
everything there is to know even like 20
years ago there was this guy what's his
name john hogan or something the end of
physics is his book like wow seriously
guy
so we haven't integrated general
relativity and quantum mechanics they
don't they won't work together physics
is obviously not not correct at all i'm
sure a lot of juniors in high school
were stoked though
yeah nothing more to learn yeah but
people have said that for a long time
and you know you think about uh sir
isaac newton who created laws of motion
yeah
you can predict uh you know how you
throw a football or how planets move
that's pretty amazing obviously that's
the final word right no einstein came
along and said well that's not really
correct so yeah i think we have a huge
amount to learn we don't even understand
dark matter and what most of the
universe consists of
uh know
people get stuck in that little
contemporary framework and think well
what else can there be i think we'll
look back in a hundred a thousand years
and say
how primitive we were what primitive
stupid creatures we were back then just
like we would look back on cave people
and kind of think poor bastards and i
don't know what we're doing back then
yeah no it's it's it's i love the the
idea of challenging your own imagination
like just because you can't imagine it
going beyond even your own imagine the
the the walls of your own imagination
that's fascinating to me here's one
thing that actually excites me about the
future people often say well what do you
what do you want to do when you come
back and obviously it'll depend on what
there is to do right there'll be a lot
of stuff i haven't even conceived of but
one thing that excites me is because i
personally am not a big fan of of of the
politics of the world right today i
think our societies are
doing things really badly in a lot of
ways we've gone in the wrong direction i
think there's far much central control
on things too much authoritarianism too
many people afraid of things and looking
to governments and authorities to solve
their problems yeah the worst uh i i
want to get i like to just like people a
few centuries ago left europe to escape
oppression and come to america and start
fresh with a free society i think
america's gone in the wrong direction
frankly and i look forward to getting
off this freaking planet and starting
new colonies new societies with new
rules where we can start fresh with all
these huge bureaucracies and politicians
start with a new constitution better
than the one we had
you know which didn't last too long
unfortunately yeah to me that's an
exciting prospect because we can't do it
here on earth everything is controlled
by somebody on earth but getting off the
planet that's a whole new ballgame man
it's so funny because i was just talking
a few weeks ago about like i wish like
america we could go to a new america
kind of like but now and then
and and then my my thought got to
first that's what i imagine man wouldn't
it be cool if we could sail off to a new
america you know but there isn't any
more right so then my imagination kind
of shut down at that point and it was
like oh we can't do it but then here you
are saying well what if the new america
is out into the spa you know it's a lot
of space out there there's no lack of
space there's huge resources like a
single asteroid can have millions of
tons of carbon and
nitrogen all kinds of materials that we
can use there's amazing amounts of stuff
out there there's no lack of resources
people are saying oh we're running out
of resources
they don't know what they're talking
about this is a whole nother issue
because a whole other area of this
course is what if there are too many
people in the future that's a whole
nother whole other thing i think people
don't think clearly about but once
you're in space there's just massive
amounts of resources and that's where
solar power actually will work because
you have direct sun power 100 100 of the
time whereas even here in arizona it
doesn't necessarily work all the time so
yeah i think getting into space really
takes away those boundaries of
possibility and uh we can try all kinds
of new social experiments if you want
your little totalitarian or socialist
society whatever you want yeah fine you
can have it just don't impose it on me i
want to have my much more free society
over here if you want like your mormon
society there fine uh yeah everybody can
have their own society if they like yeah
dude we need to build like an ark and
just figure it out
um
why do you guys station you guys are
based out of outdoors based out of
scottsdale arizona original and why it
which might seem kind of funny that
we're in a really hot place
that's a good point it's gonna cost you
more the hardest place it doesn't
actually make any difference um but it's
symbolically kind of appropriate because
we're you know in the phoenix area and
of course the phoenix is the symbol of
rising from the ashes and returning to
life so it's kind of symbolically
appropriate uh we didn't really choose
it for that reason but when we were
actually based in california we had the
phoenix as a logo now we can't do that
because it's confusing for the city yeah
um but there's two main reasons why
we're there and you know the heat
actually doesn't make any difference
once you're in our containers which we
call doers after sir james dew the metal
basically very large expensive thermos
flasks is what your patients are in it
doesn't really matter what the
temperature is we could actually put
them outside and the heat wouldn't make
a difference but like you would see at a
brewery really exactly yeah very very
similar um so the two main reasons are
and this will come back to a point i
made earlier uh one of which is uh
environmental stability like we were you
know used to be in riverside and
fullerton area well there's a huge
bloody earthquake fault right here so oh
yeah you know storing patients long-term
they're a massive earthquake for it
doesn't seem like the best idea in the
world
yeah it's a really yeah yeah even i
wouldn't do that i wouldn't do it uh
whereas where we are in that area um we
don't really have earthquakes we can
occasionally fill aftershocks from
california uh nobody's ever died in an
earthquake in arizona we don't have uh
typhoons or any kind of weather events
all we have to do is the occasional dust
storm going through so yeah it's pretty
stable but another major reason is we
had a bad time in california and today
because it's much worse in terms of the
bureaucrats here um but in the riverside
area we had some major problems um we
went through a major legal battles where
we were accused of murdering somebody by
the riverside coroner uh where the
health department then jumped on us and
said what we're doing was illegal
because there was no box on that stupid
form to check and we had to go through a
whole lot of legal battles which we won
all of but eventually you said the hell
with this and moved out to arizona um
yeah it was it was quite a time like in
1980 they accused you of murder in
someone yeah yeah it was 1988 there's
the dora kent case you can read all
about it on the website um this was the
coroner who uh this guy loved to get
publicity this is the same guy who
ordered liberace's body to be exhumed so
that he could prove that he died of aids
like
dude do you really need to do that i
mean yeah what a pervert if you don't
know liberace died of age you're an
idiot
so he'd like to get in the newspapers
and i think he looked on us and saw like
a really small organization that he
could crush and get his face in the
papers and didn't realize what he's
getting into and so what happened was
one of our members um his mother who was
83 years old i think
and she was dying we took her into the
building which we would never do anymore
for this reason
and it took a couple of days and she you
know
fired there yeah and she was declared
legally dead
and then sometime after that everything
was fine we registered the death and
everything and did the procedure
and it was it was a couple of weeks
later that uh they suddenly decided to
look at that and said well let's take a
look at this and they go i guess they
had some kind of samples and they said
there was barbiturates in their
bloodstream they said well well yeah
that's because that's what we do first
thing to stop awareness returning right
after she's legally dead now we use
profile instead but it's basically the
same thing
it's not like we killed her with that
plus what the hell is the motive for the
son who has the money killing his mother
who has no money i mean there's no
motive yeah she's 83 years old i mean do
you think she's healthy it didn't make
any sense um then they they rate it you
can find that site bring up bring up
dora ken come on help me out here you
can find it in the la times so there's
lots of stuff on that uh accuses of
stealing stuff from ucla because they
didn't bother to ask for our receipts
all these wild accusations um she looks
like groucho marx a little bit
or in that picture so yeah that's a good
story that kind of tells you everything
that happened there so you know we it
almost killed us because we didn't
really have any money at the time only
because of a couple of our members who
paid for the legal bills that we
survived this then the health department
this is typical bureaucracy the health
department then came along and said well
what you're doing is illegal oh yeah why
well because there's two boxes there's a
there's a cremation box there's a burial
box there's no box so we said well give
us a box to check and they said no
so it's a catch-22 right it's illegal
because there's no box and there's no
box because it's illegal it doesn't make
any sense yeah i thought america was a
place where things are legal unless it's
specifically a law against them that's
kind of the point of the freaking
constitution so we had to get a
constitutional attorney spend a lot more
money from our member and and we won
again but this is not the kind of place
we wanted to live really in the long
term yeah yeah we're gonna have to get
into space eventually with the group
um
so you guys end up over in uh scottsdale
what do you guys do what's the process
of keeping the bodies cool and how long
does that take like how is it
what else do you have to do so you're in
there they're in what or they're in
actually before we get to that just to
sort of finish that story the one reason
we chose scottsdale was uh we had a
member who lived in the area and he met
with the local politicians and it turns
out you know we've had the mayor of
scott still open our conferences we've
had a lot of the top council people come
do tours of alcor and they actually like
us there they boast about you know
having advanced stuff there so it's
radically different than california so i
just had to put that in there no i think
it's interesting i think a lot of that
has started to happen california's
gotten so
i don't know what it is it's gotten so
ridiculous that a lot of the creatives
have started to want to go to other
places and do different things yeah
they're leaving
arizona leaving for austin for
florida um okay so what else did we what
else were we saying what we do for the
long term too right so what kind of what
am i in if i'm in there am i do i have
my hands up or what if i do full body oh
we're gonna put you in some kind of
funny position and make funny no no no
what happens is once we've finished the
surgical procedure we've washed out the
blood and we've done the cool down uh
actually we have an operating table we
actually have a
a shape to the table to make you kind of
cool you down like this because
with your arms sticking out which makes
you hard to put it in a lot of room yeah
so we're going to actually shape you um
and then we'll put you in a sleeping bag
a high quality sleeping bag that's not
for your comfort the reason for that is
if we ever have to pull you out and
transfer you to another container the
sleeping bag will be drenched with
liquid nitrogen there we go right there
that's yeah that's the iceberg that's
where that's before we put you in the
container and are you there doing it do
you help doctor yeah i usually i usually
help out i'm not a technical person but
i'm usually overseeing and maybe
scribing making notes as to what's
happening so those are the containers so
before we put you in that container you
see there we'll first of all put you in
an aluminum pod or first of all the
sleeping bag as i said so that soaks up
liquid nitrogen in case we have to move
you it stops the temperature rising then
we encase you in an aluminum pod which
is a good temperature conductor we open
up the roof hatch which is just down
where you can't quite see it there and
then we'll put you in what you can see
here these are the aluminum doers i mean
they're so stainless steel doers which
again have a vacuum layer they're just
like very large bloody expensive thermos
flasks so you can touch the outside they
just be chilly metal but inside it's
minus 320 fahrenheit oh boy
yeah we getting in there in this picture
you can see yeah here's a fill going on
this liquid nitrogen fill we have a
truck pull up the back it fills them all
i don't know this is probably a good
humid day because we don't usually get
this much vapor but it's great for
images you've got the liquid knife oh
yeah great for huffing too boy i'd take
a hit off of that whole room
um and so actually it would kill you if
you breathe it really we have to have uh
i don't have a little you can see one on
the right actually you see that tube on
the right that's a vent so uh we have
sensors so if the if the oxygen goes
down too low because of liquid nitrogen
it'll automatically go on and suck it
out and pump in air because you will
actually suffocate if you don't get
enough oxygen oh dang so you guys are so
it's a really controlled environment how
many people do you have stored right now
uh let's see we've added a number just
recently i think we're at 196 patients
human patients okay plus something like
uh close to 100 pets
oh wow the pets are coming in yeah yeah
my own dog my own first dog is in the
oscar
falls out of your brain uh he was a big
dog he was a big doodle so no just brain
it would be expensive because you have
to do it but be almost expensive as a
human if it did the whole body and since
i'm brain only myself you know why would
i do that yeah so i actually didn't like
dogs before we had oscar i didn't want
to get one and my wife insisted on a dog
she wanted a poodle i said i'm not
walking a poodle
yeah
i'm not going to be seen walking on
poodle but we agreed on a a doodle which
is a good combination um golden
retriever and poodle
most popular dogs in scottsdale now yeah
yeah same here they're smart they're
playful they're a lot of fun um so
yeah so when he actually lasted 15 years
which is a long time for a big dog
but uh then he's got valley fever and
other things and we had to you know put
him down but we cry preserved them i
just learned about valley fever the
other day yeah such a bizarre thing
there's a weird kind of bacterial thing
i don't think i've ever had it
unfortunately but i've never heard of it
until two days ago and somebody
mentioned it um
okay so we have 196 patients
and
people can do body head or brain or
just the whole body or
we just say the neuro but that means
basically the brain kept inside the
skull just because it's easier okay
and um
and you guys have ted there the room is
always ted williams is chronically
frozen yeah he was supposed to be
private uh when people sign up they can
choose to be private or public okay uh
because some people just don't want
people to know because it's considered
unusual and we have some famous people
who are signed up who i can't name but
yeah ted williams was mentioned it was
supposed to be private but there was a
big legal battle because one of his
family said he didn't really want to do
it neither said they did and so we had
to go to court and it became public so
he's probably our most famous known
patient
we actually get people who are big
baseball fans come to visit him and
really to see where he is yeah and can
people do tours of the facility like
guided tours absolutely yeah we offer
them twice a week and we can do them by
special arrangement we like to be very
open
so you can see the place we publish case
reports to explain what we do in each of
the cases and what went right and what
went wrong
because it's not standard medicine
we think it's very important to have
very very good feedback on what we do
because you know i'm going to be in
there myself at some point i don't want
to hide anything from anybody so we're
as open as possible to hold ourselves to
account and make sure things are doing
working properly and what about bring up
that ted williams
let me see him we also have um there's
also a public member i can mention a
friend of mine hal finney whose name you
might not be familiar with but if you're
into cryptocurrencies uh you'd know his
name he was the first guy to ever
receive a bitcoin and some people think
he's the creator although he always
denied that he was really from crypto to
cryo huh yeah there's actually a lot of
people interested in both it's
interesting combination there i could
see that wow that's ted williams right
there huh and y'all you y'all just have
his brain then huh
uh yeah yeah
dang
it's a handy pretty handsome guy
wouldn't be nice there's actually
there's a novel that came out a couple
of years ago i haven't read it but it's
all about him coming back from being
query preserved and carrying on in the
future really yeah
wow
and has there been proper what
uh
and so once you get the bodies in there
um like where is ted williams brain
right now
but we don't call them bodies we call
them patients okay sorry is that no it's
okay i just i just want to say that
because in our minds they are patients
they're just like someone in a long-term
coma who we're caring for so we don't
think of this body that they're actually
patients so the patient ted williams is
in one of the doers yeah yeah so with
neuro patients um they only take up you
know as you can imagine they only take
up about a tenth of the volume of a
whole body patient so it's less
expensive to store them which is one
reason we can charge less because the
long if you're paying for long-term
storage for the you know the rent and
the insurance and maintenance obviously
is one-tenth of what is for a whole body
patient got it uh so you're in there
with uh we can convert the pod that
contains one whole body patient with
shells and have ten euro patients in the
same volume i don't know which one he's
in because that's one of our security
issues is we don't identify who's in
which doer uh just in case someone has
like a really bad enemy and wants to
come in and find them right right more
difficult but you guys know though it's
not yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah
interesting now there's a there's a the
patient is numbered the the aluminum pod
they're in extensive with the number on
there and there's lots of record keeping
we get that backed up in the cloud and
other places so it's all very successful
the room itself is secure as well of
course we take it very seriously patient
security because they can't protect
themselves so the whole room has got
like metal plates on the walls and we've
got security systems uh yeah with the
resources we have available we take that
very seriously and what if uh what do
you so what um elements do you need in
order to keep the facility maintaining
these bodies at the low temperatures
yeah so that's a common misconception as
i like to say there are two things
people know about cryonics that are
wrong one is that walt disney was was
frozen he wasn't really no he was oh
he's at forest lawn cemetery he's buried
there um i think what happened was that
there was a big chronic story at the
same time that he died and they got
mixed up somehow plus it's kind of a
natural assumption right this guy built
tomorrow world and future land and it
seemed like something he would do but no
yeah you think he just spent the adk
well he could have afforded it yeah it
would be then too but no unfortunately
not the other one is people say well you
guys are so screwed when the power goes
out like
seriously you think we haven't thought
about that in 50 years it's like no uh
we don't actually need any power to
maintain patients at that temperature
um we just refill once a week and that's
more often than we need to do with
liquid nitrogen a truck pulls out we put
liquid nitrogen into the containers that
weird as it sounds that balls off at
minus 320 fahrenheit no electricity is
needed for that at all
so the only power we need is you know
for our comfort the air conditioning
because it's in arizona um
for the computers and so on
we do need power for the operating
obviously for the surgical procedure and
for that we have a big backup generator
outside that will kick in automatically
so there's no delay in the surgery but
the patients themselves will not warm up
we could actually go for several months
without any liquid nitrogen delivery
really because it takes it only bores
off it builds maybe 12 liters a day and
so it will very slowly go down we've
done a test with an empty one you know
empty of patients it takes several
months to get low down so we could go
for months and there are many liquid
nitrogen suppliers in the area i think
something like seven of them yeah i
wonder if you guys ever had like supply
chain issues or something like that that
if there was a possibility for you guys
to at least have a uh a gap in what if
whatever you would need to keep the
bodies it's extremely unlikely where we
are again because we have so many you
know we use such a small amount compared
to like a chip company which for their
chip fab uses vast amounts of this stuff
and other companies use far more so
we're kind of like a side effect we just
use whatever's left over so it's
unlikely uh but if there was like world
war iii and we thought there's going to
be a major disruption for more than a
couple of months we can actually go out
and buy our own liquid nitrogen plant it
cost us you know probably a few hundred
thousand uh cost us twice as much per
per unit to make but we could do that
you just need power and air to make
liquid nitrogen so it's not really a
problem for us so do you feel like a
businessman or do you feel like a
explorer
is that a fair question
yeah i mean i'm um currently i'm not
really a businessman but my position
right now is ambassador i'm the guy who
comes out and explains what we do but
for almost 10 years i was the president
and ceo so i kind of ran the
organization but not really a business
man i'm more
i am i'm well i'm a philosopher by
training philosopher and economist by
training uh i did a lot of work uh with
non-profits and run other non-profits
but i don't really think i'm a
businessman as such but i i do realize
that uh you have to have an organization
that works
obviously
and you have to be able to communicate
the ideas it's not something you can
sell as such because it's not like call
now limited time you know fifty dollars
off yeah that kind of thing is not going
to work for cryonics um you know some
people say you know there's some people
who are cynics and say oh this is a scam
it's a get rich quick scheme and i i
just it makes me just kind of either
laugh or despair when they say that
because yeah this is the hardest thing
in the world to sell yeah it's the worst
thing to try and choose to get rich
quick you know that's why after 50 years
we only have like 1500 people sign up
for this you have to explain complex
ideas about life and death people have
to think about stuff they don't want to
think about they've got to make all
these arrangements this is the hardest
thing in the world to sell people on
so um you know i don't think myself for
selling but it's educating uh and this
is great to be on your show because i
get a chance to talk for like an hour or
so because it takes a long time to get
through the ideas for people to
understand what the hell is this strange
idea is about yeah and i don't and i
don't feel so too i feel just that's
what i feel a little bit more educated a
little bit more like hey what what if
your imagination or your picture of what
life is
could expand or be different
and that's interesting to me i could see
that uh flooding over into
different ways that i envision
everything i wish i had more of that in
my natural life kind of that perspective
you know because it's a lot more of a
perspective of possibility yeah
than it is a positive perspective of um
limits
one thing i would say though is if you
if you seriously do think this would be
an interesting idea
think about it sooner rather than later
because don't think well i'm not that
old now i can wait you know for another
few years because things happen and i
see this happen all the time people put
it off and then you know we get a call
at the last minute you know uncle bob
just died and can you still cry preserve
him well no we can't because the
arrangements aren't in place and it's
almost
almost impossible to do a last-minute
case like that okay in special cases
maybe we can but we don't want to take
advantage of the family financially we
want to make sure the person really
wanted to do this there's all the
contracts to sign so it doesn't work
that way you need to do this well in
advance right this is a choice you got
to make to go beyond for the bodies to
come back because the science isn't
there yet but as we see there's clues
that it could be getting there
um
man i feel really explained to it zach
do you have any other thoughts
i think my final question would be like
for theo honestly both of you
say it's 30 22 you come back it starts
what's the first thing you're doing
first thing after waking up
i'd say when is it and they'll tell me
and i go yes i made it and i want to
take a look at myself i want to know
what have newspapers but i want to know
what's going on i wonder if my wife is
back
if my dog is back you know my other
friends and just start to figure out
what's going on i think i'd just be
ecstatic actually
it'd probably be the best time of my
life that i actually made it i beat what
would be thought of as death and i'm
back and i've got all these
opportunities and that's my first
reaction and after that i don't know
depend on what's possible right what's
available
man it's a great question man
i'd probably
let me see they bring me back
show me the best movies of the last 1000
years
yeah you'd have a lot of stuff new to
watch on netflix
i'd probably honestly the first thing i
would do
is thank him
probably take a piss i bet
um
yeah i think the first thing i'd
probably do is take a piss i bet
you know how good that's gonna feel god
and then i would probably have a lunch
or some whatever they have then a new
new type of lunch or if they don't even
have lunch anymore i would see if there
was anybody who was really old that
still knew about lunch and i would ask
them if they knew right you know some
place that was still doing it was a good
place on on whatever planet we're on to
go yeah you have lunch yeah and then i
would feel yes i would be like i
did it i did it
yeah yeah
tens of billions didn't make it and i
did that would be kind of a
sad but good feeling yeah it would be
interesting and it would give you i mean
the power you would your own dna would
feel at every molecular level to be back
to just have the lights back on
that's
that's fascinating you know one thing uh
one thing i might want to just touch on
is because this usually comes up i'm
kind of surprised you haven't asked me
this maybe because you don't share this
view but a lot of people say well won't
there be too many people when you come
back aren't we overpopulated and this
isn't going to be a lot worse
and this always kind of makes me chuckle
a little bit because i've studied this
stuff for a long time i kept track of it
and what people don't seem to realize is
that's not a problem in fact we have
maybe the opposite problem coming up
fertility globally peaked around 1968 or
so it's been falling ever since uh the
us is a bit of an accession we're still
growing pretty slowly though but uh you
know all of eastern europe is shrinking
japan is shrinking germany is shrinking
uh the west of western europe is is
stopping growing and is about to shrink
as well so people are kind of stuck in a
1960s mindset of population growth
really the fact is that uh almost 40 of
the world's populations are now stopped
growing or starting to shrink and that's
going to get worse as over time goes on
even africa you know its fertility is
dropped massively and when they reach a
certain level of wealth and women have
more opportunities they stop having
children
so even the u.n which is consistently
overpredicted population even the u.n
says by about 2080 or the end of the
century global population not just
western which will stop a lot sooner
global population will peak and start
falling wow and the scary thing is
there's no bottom you can go to zero um
so i don't think you know population is
a problem in that sense in fact we'll
want people to live longer so we don't
shrink the population so fast and this
is even regardless of going into space
well yeah even growing up i remember my
neighbors growing up they had like seven
children and my neighbor the neighbors i
have now have only two children yeah if
any yeah a lot of people don't have any
of these days he's getting a lot less
out there um so that's not an issue nor
is resources you know people are
panicking about energy and resources
those are all political problems it's
because of
stupid policies that we're we're not
actually not now energy what about this
what if you say i get frozen right my
grandkid are like oh [ __ ] we didn't even
know him
shut it down we don't want to do it
anymore how do i get protected
oh well they don't have any choice in
that i mean you've made the arrangements
your agreement is with the alcor
foundation and that's our contractual
obligation that's what we do we
certainly be in big trouble if we ever
did that at someone else's wish and
that's why we've had legal battles
because we've said absolutely no we're
doing what the patient wishes and you're
not going to stop it so
somebody who doesn't want you to
continue being cry brazil has no no word
and no say in the word legally and this
is an interesting point actually because
it will change i think at some point in
the future right now legally when you're
cry preserved
in the eyes of the law you're donating
yourself
uh to a scientific experiment basically
ah because we're you know we're a
non-profit organization scientific
educational organization you're
basically donating yourself biologically
as an experiment now that's not the way
we see it because we see you as a
patient but at some point in the future
i think we will you know when this
speaking ideas become more familiar
you'll have some kind of legal status
you'll be someone who can't be just
taken out or an armed yanked off just
like someone right now in a long-term
coma in a hospital you can't just go in
there and take their foot off or take
out their kidney they have certain
rights so right now you you know we
literally we own your ass right now
legally speaking but at some point i
think you will have a legal status like
someone in the coma but relatives can't
just come and yank you out no
and why what what do people want their
pets to become back if oh usually people
get frozen with their pets right no no
no usually well no we don't it's not
like the uh the egyptians who you know
when the pharaoh died they killed all
the
all the servants and buried them with
them we do we don't do that with the
pets now generally the pets are a cry
observe first and you may even have
several of them by that time
um i don't think we've really had a case
of when a member has died and then what
happens to their pets i think they're
usually adopted by someone else what
about the smallest pet you got any hamps
in there any hamsters uh probably i
think the smallest uh we actually have
two
what do you call those things little
furry things
nothing's smaller than that oh gerbils
no ferret ferrets no no is it a ferret
oh guinea pigs it's not a gigantic
oh great something it's something like a
ferret i think it's it's got a different
name it's it's a really cute very very
soft thing sugar glider it's super soft
what do they call those things it's kind
of ferretish but oh um it's really
really cool sean huh oh i'm trying
that's dog i don't remember what it is i
forget the name but yeah those are
really kind of you can't do the surgery
on those very well because they've got
tiny blood vessels so they may not uh
get the full treatment pull up a guinea
pig man it could be a jeep baby i'm
trying to think what that thing's called
it's uh it's extremely soft that's why
they're so popular
let's see one let's click on one we did
have a we had a a crank call once a few
years ago
no it's kind of you know
but these are beautiful i remember later
on it's too late
we did get a crank call one time it was
kind of funny someone called us up and
said
well i have a pet octopus do you charge
by the by the the tentacle or what
[Laughter]
yes
[Music]
that's
insane somebody would do that um what
about that population is population
growth that's really going down yeah oh
it's bringing the growth has been going
down and down and absolute population
levels are getting actually going down
in many countries you always hear all
this population fear what is all that i
know it's it's bizarre it's very
outdated it's like people haven't where
do we find information that population
is going down is it out there uh a world
in data is a good place again yeah you
can find it pretty much anywhere even
wikipedia which is not reliable on a lot
of stuff well i hope population
look population can do whatever it wants
i think it's fascinating man it's
fascinating to be like kind of like a um
you know uh like a kind of a christopher
columbus on the
on the plane of time you know cryonot
sometimes yeah yeah sort of restaurant
yeah yeah christopher cryolombus
i think this was really fascinating max
man i really appreciate it i i think
it's it's intriguing to think of it
makes me think of what a new um
what type of like
[Music]
non-profits people could even get
involved in it it expands the idea of
where i even think of nonprofits being
and what they're doing
um
i thought it was gonna be a lot more
expensive honestly yeah most people do
they think it's only for rich people and
it's really not the case again life
insurance makes it affordable especially
if you're fairly young it's quite easily
affordable um but again despite that
it's growing pretty slowly you know
there's only three or four organizations
in the states there's one in china
there's one starting up in australia
there's one starting in switzerland uh
one in russia which is kind of a
disaster as you might expect yeah
so there's really not that many
worldwide but it is it's gradually
growing i like to think when i started
when i joined i was member number 67 now
we have 1 500 i think there were three
patients now we have 196 so we're
getting there slowly but i think
there'll be some point we'll look back
on at some point in the future and this
would be normal this would be the thing
that is normal to do and people will
just scratch their heads and wonder why
the hell did people destroy their loved
ones going to bury them or cremate them
when they could have done this how weird
is that so this won't seem like the
weird idea what we're doing now will
seem weird in the future
well i i that's exactly what i'm
thinking about it was like when you were
talking about getting to the moon what i
pictured was two guys and one of them
has a ladder and the guys one guy's like
there's no way we can do it you know and
then i thought about like burial was
like yeah putting someone in the ground
or cremating them
so if
everything's kind of evolving
it's like um
eventually yeah burial would be like
well you got to get saved you like why
would yeah like somebody be like oh we
have my grandma there's like a nft like
a real life nft you know we ever like
saved you know with alcor you know or
saved cryonically
um
uh about being a normal thing in the
future whereas you know it's seen as
kind of bizarre and strange now but i
think it'll be perfectly normal it'd be
the standard thing in the future
yeah crazy to do the opposite yeah be
crazy like what are you just going to
burn him yeah that since that's crazy i
love him
i'm going to love him i want to be eaten
by worms and bacteria what
yeah it's like we keep everything baby
you're the freaking
dude you're like the
i mean you're the liaison of leftovers
man you're talking about long term baby
i mean if you hate uncle fred okay barry
i'm burying my burning but if you like
the guy why would he do that or bring
him back later and we'll [ __ ] him up
down the line you know if you want but
whatever to have the opportunity yeah
you know the possibility i like that man
uh dr max moore thank you so much for
coming in thanks for having me it's been
great yeah i really appreciate it
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i can feel it
[Music]